some of these authors have appeared on
book tv you can watch them on our
website booktv.org
and now on book tv we're live for book
tv's monthly in-depth fiction edition
program with novelist gish jen
her books include typical american
mona in the promised land and world and
town
guess jen
you wrote in 2009 that quote john updike
chose me as his successor
i never got to ask him why i know
successor to what though oh that's an
interesting question what happened was
that there was a magazine in london and
um
and they were doing um this millennial
special right so it was the term that is
it was
the turn of the century and so they
asked all these people who they thought
were preeminent in their fields
to name their successor for the 21st
century
right so um
kate twiggy
chose kate moss
and um john updike for reasons i never
understood chose me
you know i mean so here's this
incredibly august man of letters i'd
never met him i didn't know he even knew
my name
and um yeah i know he had our picture
taken together and but i never i never
got i never got to ask him why are you a
fan of john updike well you know of
course i am a fan you know and i you
know but i would not have said that he
was a major influence on me except for
someone indirectly you know i mean
indirectly he was a fan he was an
influence on us all
and that's because
brighter like me here i am i've got
immigrant roots you know i'm very
interested in america i see america the
way a tour sees america you know what i
mean like it's all fresh and new news
everything is interesting of course i
want to write about it
and
you know i think uptake is give us give
us all the idea that that was what the
novel was for
um the the novel was was for capturing
america and writing america and is part
of the the adventure of inventing
america so he had that rabbit series the
whole idea was to capture america in
these books right you know um rabbit run
of course rabbit is rich redux rabbit
rest
and that that was his project and i
think he could see in me somebody i
think maybe he maybe understood that
that was you know that there was more to
america than just what we saw in the
rabbit books and i think maybe he saw me
as somebody who was going to carry on
that project and that he was right you
know he was right um there was also
something else that was sort of really
interesting about um updike and that of
all the things that he valued in fiction
um he really valued people who had what
he called a fervent relationship with
the world
and he liked this this quality that he
said he called the the nose pressed the
glass quality and of course
you know there's no one who has their
nose pressed more firmly to the to the
glass
than the daughter of immigrants right so
here i am in this world and yeah that's
my nose that he's talking about um so
there is a way in which update was
hugely influential
although i would not have said that you
know i was because probably before
meeting him and and kind of thinking
about you know how he had
influenced me in this indirect way i
probably would have said something like
oh well you know white wasp author you
know i'm writing against him right i
probably would have said that but in
truth
even as i wrote maybe a little bit
against people like that i was actually
carrying on their deeper project
you know i mean to write against them to
think that you were riding against them
is really it's like it's like this is
like um rebelling against your parents
you know you're going against your
parents it's all about your parents you
know
specifically i think i'm writing against
updike but it's kind of all about updike
so when you look at some of your novels
typical american world in town
monae in the promised land short stories
and who's irish are you writing the
great american novel you know i don't
think of myself that way do you mean i
mean i don't think um i don't know if
there is a great american novel you know
but i do think of myself as adding to
the american narrative you know so if
you ask me like you know what did i
imagine i was what in my wildest dreams
like what is the kind of the ultimate
thing that i'm doing right um i would
say that people not just me but lots of
people like me that we're trying to add
a volume to the library of america do
you mean um the way that the jews did
you know the way that we we can't tell
the story of america without updike
right and then the jews did it it's like
you know what you know you can't talk
about the 20th century without the jews
and that is finally their way of saying
like we are
really here you know we're not here as
visitors and you know we're not just
tourists passing but we are
really here
and there's a way in which i think me
maxine on kingston so many of us vietnam
now we're all you know we're all sort of
saying and you know what
us too we are also here
and um
and yeah so this is you know this is
this so there is a way like i say i
don't think it's about
the great american novel
but it is about adding you know to our
picture of america in in a permanent way
well you mentioned saul bellow as one of
your favorite writers the jewish ghetto
experience is there
an asian-american genre i don't know
that there's an asian american genre but
i do think that there's a way in which
you know i was very influenced by the
jewish why did you you've done your
homework you know that
and um
but you know when i think about
what they meant to me
it was really kind of an example of what
was involved in adding this volume to
the library of america um and that is
that
you know they took such a different tax
if you think about the jewish writers
right it's not just bellow you know it's
bellow it's malamud it's roth it's
cynthia ozick
it's grace paley my very dear grace
paley and um you know they all
they were all going at kind of the same
problem but in such different ways right
so billow took the high road you know
meaning
you know no ethnic markers very hard to
tell he's jewish in many ways you know
and we all know he's jewish but you know
no ethnic markers because he knows it's
going to make him an ethnic writer he
doesn't want to do that right
roth does the exact opposite you know
it's just like i am jewish and you you
know what i mean and you know here it is
in your face america right
malama takes i avoid love i love malin
it takes a much more soulful you know
kind of approach
um grace paley rejects the idea that you
must be only be a writer that you you
know that writer's not part of your
social activism she's out in the streets
all the time protesting all the time
cynthia osic manages to make her her
name
you know synonymous with henry james you
know i think it's something that we
really don't appreciate today you know
kind of what hutzpah it took for this
jewish american girl
to to make herself the person that every
time you write anything about henry
james today the review of blah blah blah
you know we always have to go to cynthia
ozek you know this jewish girl she's the
expert you know that's this there's a
lot of husband but what i took away and
this goes back to your question about
the great american novel
is that
all of the above
the answer is there's no one path
there's no one way of doing what we need
to do we need to do all the ways we need
to use all the registers and we must all
just be going at it in every possible
way so when you like you see you know it
would like i say you know whether it's
bringing in the jewish humor bringing
it's bringing the jewels the jewish
selflessness and that you know
tremendous deep sense of morality um
whether you know what i mean whether
we're going to take the mandarin road
whether we're going to identify with
henry james whether we're going to be in
the streets
the answer is
all of the above because we have a big
challenge ahead of us most of your
protagonists nearly all of your
protagonists are asian american women
could you write a white male of course
wasp of course lead of course well first
of all you know ralph chang and typical
american is male so it's not they aren't
all asian american women
and actually my very first published
story
um had no ethnic markers at all so my
very first published story was a call a
story called bellying up um what
happened was that i was in the iowa
writers workshop it's 1981.
um i am i am in a forms class what was
called the forms class with a writer
named barry hannah
rather a sexist guy i will say
um anyway barry had this contest in his
class
which was the raymond carver writer-like
contest and um
so the idea was what was you know we're
supposed to might write this piece and
send it into him right
well the women uh perceiving i think
probably accurately that a woman would
never win this contest we all signed our
our stories raymond carver right
um and i did write this story um and i
did win um i was i still remember when
he held up my story said who wrote this
piece building up and i thought oh [ __ ]
it's me it's so embarrassed but anyway
um
but that very first piece had nothing
there's nothing asian asian american
anything about the protagonist a guy
named barry
who's lost his job and he's um he's
waiting for his uh girlfriend to come
out of the bathroom where she's clearly
hiding from him
um
and uh
yeah no it's um anyway so i can write
that i mean like i said i got that you
know i want a contest with it you know i
kind of i publish it's clear that i can
do that um
of course one of the when i talk about
all the different ways we had to kind of
go about remaking america through our
writing project
of course given the you know the paucity
of asian american asian american women
on the page of course you know it's part
of my project not to write about them
narrowly like it's just like you know
it's about you know they're all about
mothers and daughters
but to show that you know you can be
writing about religion fundamentalism
you know whatever you're writing about
the nature of art
there is nothing about using
an asian american female protagonist
that's at odds with writing about any of
these big subjects you know the answer
is of course of course because
asian american women like people
everywhere
are concerned with religion with with
with politics you know with
you know with every big possible
question right it's not like they're in
this little
you know groove where they only worry
about what it means to be asian american
right
often here on book tv we hear about the
iowa writers workshop
how has that sustained itself what does
it do that makes it so successful well
it was the earliest workshop right um so
it was you know back so when at the time
that i applied to iowa
there were really only three big
programs now they're a gazillion but
that's you know that's a big change um
so there was iowa stanford and hopkins
but you know iowa was um was like five
times bigger than any of the programs
you know so i mean i they're funny
because at the time i was actually you
know you probably know i dropped out of
stanford business school to become a
writer so i said stanford there's many
ways in which it would have been
convenient to go to stanford my my
boyfriend now husband was there and
but you know i just sort of felt like
you know this is a much bigger
you know program it's like you're gonna
you're gonna see more there's just more
coming in and out so i think it got that
early um it had kind of that early
advantage um also you know iowa did not
have a schtick hopkins had a little bit
of a schtick you know
um
a little bit because of john barth um
and um you know i was always a place
where they kind of just let you be
you know and kind of kind of encourage
you to do whatever that meant
um it was for me a fantastic choice as
it happened
because my first teacher there very
influential figure for me was james
allen mcpherson jimmy pearson um
you know pulitzer prize-winning author
wrote elbow room many other very
wonderful books um and who was
conveniently for someone like me an
immigrant who kind of didn't really know
what america was i was kind of busy
discovering america i had my nose up
against the glass
and he was interested in writing about
america you know many years later um
you know long after we graduated from
iowa one of my classmates um gave me a
birthday present and what was the
present you know the president was a
posters from a woman named eileen
pollock
um
she the poster was was a this picture
with a photograph and underneath it were
the words american vision
and you know that's what mcpherson was
talking about all the time it's kind of
like you know kind of this invention
that was america the american project
like what did that mean
and um and the idea that that was part
of what we should be doing as writers
you know that's not what everybody
thinks a fighter should be doing
many people would say well that's kind
of you know you're too close to you're
you're too close to a social project you
know that this is not you know this is
not about art for art's sake right
you're because you're sort of very much
in dialogue with with with um your
context um
so some people say well that's not you
know the highest purest i don't really
care if it is or not anyway
luckily for me um that first teacher um
was not interested in art for art's sake
you know he was interested in in a kind
of novel that was yeah very much
involved with america
and um
yeah so iowa for me was just a was just
a great choice because there are other
wonderful teachers too there i will say
but that's another thing they have the
teachers coming in and out so there's
just you know there's not like one big
writer who's kind of dominating the
program you've got a lot of different
people coming in it's kind of constant
dialogue it's a wonderful
thing and i was a very interesting place
to be i will say for somebody like me it
was very bi-coastal right
i said i will tell you when i first got
to iowa
you know it's this tiny you know it's
tiny little airport you know and my
father had come with me and um you know
there's you know they didn't have a jet
way or anything like that they you know
they basically said they bring the
luggage out it's basically
you know a little garage they open the
door
you can see the you know the the air
master right behind it and and somebody
went and took my
my um suitcase and put it out my father
immediately said that's her suitcase you
know because we're from new york it's
like
he says oh no i'm just helping you sir
you know i mean they you know it's it
was a you know it was it's it was a it
was a revelation to us i will say both
the friendliness but also kind of
you know the xenophobia i will say too i
mean it is also a place where
i'm another writer ben huang and i you
know with like the two asian americans
around and we were once uh you know
hitchhiking and
you know it's like people are just like
who are you you know we went to a bar
and everybody stopped talking you know
so it was you know a little xenophobic
as well so i don't want to play to just
kind of paradise
but there's a there was something else
though there too which is very you know
very warm and friendly and no one is
stealing your your suitcase you know
um
so it was kind of both well wasn't it
just recently in your hometown of
cambridge massachusetts that uh somebody
told you to go back to where you came
from yeah that happened yesterday it
happened yesterday you saw that on
facebook yeah i was in i was a fresh
pond i do live in
cambridge massachusetts as you say which
is very liberal and you know
generally you know just a kind of
idyllic place in general but
not entirely right so um i was there um
i was there to walk with a friend and
you know it is it is a place where you
only cambridge residents are supposed to
be parking and but many other people do
come and park there and walk around the
pond and there was this woman kind of
patrolling up and down unofficially
unofficially of course to make make sure
that everybody there really had a
cambridge parking sticker and she's
controlling down and um but really
yelling at people you know i was like
what are you doing here you know i'm the
one who pays taxes to support this place
what are you doing here
and then she got to me and she said
where's your sticker and i said well you
know what's up it's up here you know
it's um cambridge just this year changed
the the place where you put your
stickers like up until last year you put
your sticker in the back of the car this
year you know it's in the front of the
car honestly you can you know usually
just see all the stickers in the back
you can tell someone's been there like
for 15 years and we do have cars where
there's like 15 years of stickers in the
back but anyway my sticker's in the
windshield and i said what's right here
he said she didn't clearly didn't
believe me
she said what color is it and i said to
her
you know i said why don't you know you
know why do you want to know well you
know why should i tell you and she said
i'm protecting people
and i said i don't think you're
protecting people i think harassing
people and that she immediately says you
know what do you mean i'm harassing
people you go home you know go back to
where you came from
just like that you know it's amazing
just write a news so the answer is you
know i think this is true of all places
that there are two faces depends on who
you're talking to you know there's kind
of a general culture
then there's always some undertale now
you've referred to yourself against jen
as an immigrant a couple of times
weren't you born in new york you know
the daughter of daughter of him and his
daughter who was daughter of immigrants
um yes no i was born in long island
and um no i you know i'm second
generation and did i say i was an
immigrant i usually don't make that slip
i will say
um but no i'm a daughter of immigrants
born in um
on the long island
you took a rather circuitous route to
get to the iowa writers workshop
walk us through that
well you know should i go back to the
very beginning
why don't we start with college we'll go
back to the beginning little bit later
but you were you were going to be a
doctor a ceo you had whatever
yeah well you know
there i was an english major you know i
was at harvard i was an english major
undergrad undergrad
um
and you know as an english major i did
take this course um english 283 which is
diversification with the wonderful um
translator robert fitzgerald you know
whose translations of the iliad and the
odyssey are still my favorite of course
and
i took this course because i felt i was
a junior and i was an english major and
i didn't really understand why poetry
had to be written in those little lines
like why don't they just say what they
mean right
so i um
so i took this course and i thought you
know if you know if i take this course
i'll finally understand and that was
true
um but what i didn't realize is that you
know he said there was going to be a
weekly exercise and i did not realize
that he meant in a weekly exercise in
verse
like i thought it was going to be like a
paper so like the very first week i was
just like oh my god i'm supposed to
write something in catalan hendica
syllables you can always i can barely
say headache of syllables today i was
like catella and kinda great but i sat
down to write my poem and as soon as i
started writing it
i loved it and i did say to my roommate
at the time i said you know i just love
if i could do this for the rest of my
life i would
but you know i'm the daughter of
arrogance people just i had never known
a writer i mean that people like me did
not become poets you know it's like it
just you know it's so you know i so i
was pre-med at the time and i'd already
been pre-law you know i was like read
this be that and but fitzgerald is the
one who sat me down he sort of said
so why are you pre-med
the question i really couldn't answer
very well since i could just gotten a c
in chemistry i think
there are other signals that maybe this
is really not the right path for me um
but fitzgerald was the one to say you
know i think you should do something
with words and if you're not going to be
a poet which is really what he thought i
should do
um you know he should at least like
be in publishing or something you know
he did give me my first job and would
not i now realize realizes one of those
kind of legendary harvard stories you
know he
um he called up his editor um pike
johnson at double day and said i have
the student
give her a job
and so my first job was in publishing um
you know that said you know i had been
pre-law i had been pre-med um even after
i was already in publishing you know and
i had taken my first writing class at
the new school
and uh that teacher too had said you
know he had said you know what this
little piece about dogs and henry james
i don't know and he
you know he said you know you should
really be a writer so people had told me
that
um but even so yes i was beginning to
get the idea that maybe i was interested
in writing
but then i wanted to do something
practical and so i thought well if i
can't decide well maybe i'll try the
more practical
course first you know if i can't decide
between being more you know i guess i
felt as publishing was in between i was
neither going to be able to make a
living nor i was going to you know be
able to do what i wanted
and i went to stanford business school
of all places
very confused young woman um i went to
stanford over harvard because they had a
good writing program like i say was very
confused and um i got there actually i
met my my now husband you know almost
the first day and um
he had exempted out of everything i'm so
impressed not only did he know what all
these courses were i mean i was like
what is statistics you know
what is microeconomics um he accepted
everything and i said oh my god you know
like that is so great that means you can
take courses courses across the street
meaning at the regular university not
the business school
and he just looked at me said but that's
not what i'm here for and i remember
thinking
he knows what he's here for
i was like what was
the first five minutes like i think
you're totally the wrong place
um
and so i did um you know i was intending
to finish you know i i am the daughter
of immigrants you know start a program
and then just drop out you know
but i found the first day of the second
year
that you know i overslept
the second day i overslept
the third day
i overslept it was equally clear by
friday i was never going to be able to
get myself to go to class
so i took a leave of absence and i went
to china for the year instead it's a
wonderful year in china
um but you know what's very funny my
business school class still claims me
you know so they always say you know
there are two well-known dropouts from
this class you know one is gishgen and
one is steve ballmer who made a ceo of
microsoft
two very very different outcomes um
but in any case i i did drop out my
parents
could not forgive me for doing this i
mean for me for several years my mother
did not speak to me and um
but you know
you know i i mean literally did not
speak to you you literally did not make
me very very upset
um but you know
you know this is america you know i have
been growing the self i will say partly
because i grew up in scarzel partly
because i have been reading
you know what i mean i have been reading
really all these subversive books giving
me all the acs and i have been you know
growing this american south
um that was very very different than the
nice chinese girl itself and um you know
and i just i just kind of crossed that
line where
i i couldn't go back to you know the
nice the lillian jen that they know of
my youth i i you know i couldn't go back
anymore and i had to go forward well if
you are tuning into book tv right now
and are a little surprised to see a
novelist
on this is part of our special in-depth
fiction edition all year long on the
first sunday of the month we are
featuring
novelis and this month we're pleased
that gish jen is joining us very quickly
here are some of her books if you are
not familiar with her typical american
came out in 1991 mona in the promised
land in 96
who's irish a collection of short
stories in 1999
the love wife in 2004 world in town came
out in 2010 her most recent books happen
to be non-fiction tiger writing in 2013
and the girl at the baggage claim is
from
last year she's going to be our guest
for the next two and a half hours so if
you would like to dial in and talk with
her here's how you can do so 202 is the
area code 748 8200 for those of you in
the east and central time zones
202-748-8201 if you live out west or in
the mountains you can also contact us
via social media at book tv is our
handle for facebook instagram as well as
twitter
and our email booktv
cspan.org now we'll cycle through those
as the show goes you'll see them on the
bottom of your screen so you don't don't
worry if you don't didn't catch it right
now
but
guess jen
in your writing and i want to start with
who's irish first of all
your husband's last name is o'connor did
that influence the title of this
collection of short stories well of
course it's one of the reasons i know so
much about what it means to be
irish-american right because i married
an o'connor and he does come from one of
those boston clans you know what i mean
like they've been there forever and you
know everybody's related everybody else
and so i know a little bit about that
world
did you get blowback for
that essay and the dialect that the uh
narrator used the pigeons no i did not i
did not it's kind of surprising what
about from yourself did you have trouble
writing it that way
well what is true is that um you know
there to be an ethnic writer in america
means so many things you know i mean
there's so many ways in what you're
going to kind of see that your identity
is that you are in dialogue with your
society right um but one of the
ways for me is that you know it's clear
to me that i could not write in that
voice if i'd written that same story
before typical american
you know and sent it to the new yorker
i'm sure they would have sent it back
and sort of said you know be you know
wonderful story be
happy to you know hear from you when
your english is better right in other
words they would not have seen that it
was artificed they would have thought
that i just didn't know english very
well so it's kind of i was that the
story really depends on the fact that i
had already established myself as
somebody who's very fluent in english um
and you know so i had to you know even
just saying i had already established
that authorial um voice or the fact that
i was an author you know and so that
this is artifice um
and um so there's kind of permission you
know so each book gave me permission to
write a new kind of book you know and of
course i had already written one in the
promised land and kind of this you know
new york jewish voice so kind of you
know to go from a new york at that point
to you know to write in another kind of
voice an immigrant chinese voice um
was something that you know i mean i
already done the jewish voice so i could
do this voice too right um but you're
right there's a way in which i had to
kind of um
i had to kind of establish myself in a
way to write in a voice that was very
familiar to me you know because there
was a way in which you know my parents
grew up
brought us up english speaking but in
truth we spoke a lot of chinglish you
know and which is just a very natural
thing when you're speaking to people who
you know who's english for whom english
is not their first language
interestingly just not
just recently my daughter and i went to
go visit my mother in the hospital my
daughter across is born here and you
know doesn't really have that much
contact with chinese culture and but i
could hear her simplifying her speech
to get across to my mother you know
because my mother it's not that she her
english isn't good but you know she's
sick and she's you know she's a little
out of it and
and i could hear her simplifying the
speech and i'm like oh my god my
daughter is speaking to english that's
kind of interesting right so there's a
way it's kind of parked all the way back
there even for her
um but in any case yes you know for this
for this um story i did kind of um go
back to what maybe was probably my first
language really
um and um are you fluent in mandarin no
no no no no anyway but my friends are
shanghai anyway um so no i've you know
i'm the sort of perennial in chinese uh
student i said you know i
when i'm in beijing
people always say to me like you know
you can't say anymore that you don't
speak chinese you actually do speeches
but i'm not fluent and so i feel bad
because if i if i speak chinese i sound
good enough that people will come back
to me at native speed and that's like
very very fast and i can't follow it
when it's that fast
um but i will say that yes but you know
my first language my first english was
very heavily um
um overlaid with chinese everything
including chinese grammar so i will say
that when i studied chinese the grammar
was no problem i'm like oh yeah subject
you know
i mean just the order of things it was
completely natural to me because in fact
my early english you know we were
speaking in that order see how even
talking about it you see how my english
is getting a little screwed up you know
um so the answer is that you know the
sentence structures somewhat um were
very natural to me
p-i-d-g-i-n pidgin english you know
where that term comes from
i don't know where it comes from
do you no i don't i was hoping you would
i should know yes jen you talk about
mona and writing in a jewish voice
but mona was a chinese-american girl
from
scars hill
new york
a little bit of a biographical element
to that well there is you know because i
grew up in scarsdale new york it's you
know scars hill and the novel is
obviously um
a relative uh you know of of scars dale
um and of course you know i was
interested in that because as i'm saying
we're interested in writing about
america it was fascinating to me that
you know i've grown up in a place where
a minority was the majority right
um and also you know just at a point in
you know 19
this book is set 1968 right and so just
to the point where you know on the heels
of the civil rights movement you know
the blacks are saying you know i'm black
and i'm proud and the jews are saying
i'm jewish and i'm proud and i was
supposed to stand up and sort of say you
know i'm asian i'm proud i'm you know i
think it's like i'm asian and i'm
jewish you know which is true i think of
most people in the new york area the
fact of the matter is that you know the
jewish culture is very much informed
like the way that we joke everybody
knows yiddish you know and um
and so i guess i was interested you know
in in this hybrid self um and i will say
that that that sort of that you know
that jewish you know that jewish tinged
voice
was also a voice that i knew
amazingly well you know so there's a way
in which yeah i know i know i know this
dialect of english extremely well um
very very easy for me to write in it um
and um and i thought that that in itself
spoke to the kind of the actual
complexity of life in america and the
answer is like right now it's very you
know it's very fashionable people to
sort of say like you know i need to go
to college and i need to see somebody
who looks like me
or you know that reflects me and i'm
like well who exactly would that be
you know for me it would have to be
somebody who came from one background
but grew up in in new york and therefore
had become a little jewish you know
so um so you know i mean i was like you
know i mean i think it's too simple to
sort of say somebody who looks like me
they have black hair is like me i'm
thinking you know that's that's just not
the case
when you're in china do chinese know
you're american
um you know it's interesting sometimes
yes sometimes no
right
my students when i was i'm i taught at
um beijing normal university for for a
semester year of sars
and my students would say that um
they would know me by the way i walked
so i walk in this american way yeah so
if i was not walking they would not know
but once i started walking they would
know
you know
202 is the area code 748 8200 for those
of you in the east and central time
zones 202-748-8201
for those of you in the mountain and
pacific time zones let's hear from ken
who's calling in from atlanta hi ken
ken are you with us
whoops sorry about that i don't know
where can it maybe if i push the button
can you hear me okay can i apologize to
you
it's my fault please go ahead
well miss jan um
i work with the georgia general assembly
and all 50 legislatures
are about to roll out a project in
citizenship this year and we're going to
encourage the students
in every school
to get together and do the stories
about their own
elementary high school
and we've discovered not only in georgia
but other places
that most americans
are
associated with organizations like
religions and
schools and government
and know almost nothing
about the organization
that they spend
most of their lives associated with
and i just wanted to
let you know about it because we're also
going to reach
professional writers
so that they can be
available to the schools where they went
to school right
where you went to elementary school
and high school
and you would being an artist like you
are
it would be a great example
for young people
and um
i just wanted to share the idea with you
well that is a fantastic idea you know
and i have to say that you know i'm i
have written a lot about growing up in
scarsdale new york and i would be
thrilled that they were to invite me
back and i think that um
and i i will say also that you know
while you're inviting people should
definitely invite people who from other
areas as well you know um i don't know
if you know the the group um
penn faulkner in washington you know but
they they bring writers from all over
the world into the dc schools and i
would encourage you to get in touch with
them and see whether you can likewise be
bringing writers from all over into your
schools i have to say that this program
is fantastically successful really a
great delight for the writers and of
course for the students it's just a
fantastic thing as well so i think more
power to you gish jen you've mentioned
your parents a couple of times
who were they are are they oh well my my
my father has passed away my mother is
still alive um
my parents were immigrants from china so
um what happened in um the 19 1943
would be my father before the end of the
war so what happened in my father's case
um
is that um
you know there was talk during the war
the second world war of opening a second
front against the japanese in the
shanghai harbor so they needed
hydraulics engineers to help coordinate
this effort
and um
and so they had an exam that's how i do
things in you know this is
transportation department had this exam
uh my father scored very highly high on
this exam and so um he was one of the
people who was supposed to help
coordinate this so he they needed him to
go to the united states um so he was
sent um of course you couldn't
you couldn't cross the pacific is too
dangerous so we went all the way
overland you know to india over the hump
as they say the malia's into india all
the way across europe all across the
atlantic by the time he got the united
states the war was over
um but he did stay um you know to get
his phd here at the university of
minnesota um and then um you know he
because he was getting with the
intention of of going back um but then
in 1949 of course the communists took
over
and um
and what is really not a very well known
chapter of american history of the us
government struck a deal with the
nationalists in china
to keep the chinese students here so
you're going to say at the time and it
got all the cream of the chinese you
know science community were in the
united states you know like my father
getting their phds and um they all
wanted to go back
um but people would try to go back and
literally they were taken off the boats
in hawaii you know they were not allowed
to go back because the fear was that all
these scientists would go back and help
the communists
so they were stuck here um my father uh
was offered citizenship then under a
refugee act uh my father said i'm not a
refugee you know i am a political
prisoner he refuses american citizenship
and um so you know that's you know i
grew up with an undocumented father you
know my father was an illegal citizen he
was actually a stateless citizen it was
not really clear what country it was
this country
um
and um
you know but but he was i will say very
good at engineering uh my mother came
interestingly you know um there had been
a plan to kind of marry her off while
she had not wanted to be married off
and kind of in the in ensuing
um uh awkwardness i guess um they sent
her off um to to get an um
a graduate degree in america as well
um and so she and she also got
caught here
um
she was a citizen because she had come
via her local her church she was she'd
gone to a catholic church in high school
in shanghai and so um she was affiliated
with the church and so they they helped
her become a citizen so if she became
citizen my father like like i say would
have nothing to do with it
you know so they i will say they had you
know of course you know being an
immigrant then was really a very rough
thing
um you know my father
my father tremendous sense of humor so
we'd always tell these stories with a
laugh but
and you know you tell stories like about
when he first got here how you know it
was not
people did not think the chinese could
do engineering it's kind of a funny
thing today given the stereotypes that
we have today by the time they didn't
think they could do engineering so my
father's out in the field
with a bunch of um you know um
us army people and um
you know they they have this guy with
them so they gave him an algebra book
to study i thought he could you know and
he gave it back the next day and they
said
you finished that book in one night he
said yeah yeah yeah you know
the next night the next day they gave
him another book geometry
morning he gives it back he said you
finished that book oh one night yeah
yeah yeah they give him a trigonometry
book right meanwhile they're out in the
field they're trying to fix this bridge
and bridge is a truss bridge and they
want to um replace one of these trusses
and they're having a lot of trouble
doing that and my father says you know
why don't you put a truck on the end of
the bridge and then you can fix your
bridge he says on the first day
of course they ignore him because he's
chinese what does he know you know
they're giving this you know second day
he says
why don't you put a truck on the end of
the bridge and then you can fix that
truss and
ignore him the third day he says why
didn't you put a truck on the end of
this on the region finally they put a
truck on the en on the end of the bridge
and of course it takes the weight off
the truss and they can fix the truss you
know my father always told the story
like it was the funniest thing ever like
can you believe it you're giving me this
you know i mean a lot of people today
would be offended that's because you
know in our time the thing that we like
you know people everyone is offended all
the time my father always just thought
like what is the matter with that
they can't fix the bridge i can't figure
out you know that the person who can fix
the bridge is right with it you know um
but in truth of course this is just the
story of his life and like i said he
laughed about it but
a lot of it was very difficult um
and uh he was um he did among other
things you know work on the beltway
right here in dc
so one of the engineers but you know
the chinese engineers then um they did a
lot of this kind of work um but they
always did it as kind of you know the
equivalent of an adjunct professor today
you know so they didn't have real jobs
they were just hired for the job at the
end of the job they were all fired
and um they never you know i mean they
were never promoted into management ever
and um
and to my father you know there was a
lesson in that it wasn't so much he was
mad about it
so much as it you know told him that you
know this is a tough place
and um
yeah i guess it kind of instilled the
kind of realism in him about you know
what he was going to have to do
um
to make it here you know and that
realism is
if you think about it you know it kind
of
a very flexible view of that too i will
say it's kind of willing to do whatever
it took and um i think it's related to
my idea about the jewish writers that
kind of you know i mean actually you try
all the different ways there's not one
way but all the different ways my father
was very much of that cast in mind as
well gish gen 1949 occurs in a lot of
your books why is that
well of course that's you know that's
that's the the year china is liberated
or fell depending on your perspective
um and you know that's it's just a huge
you know that's a huge historical moment
and it is the time for
pretty much i guess every chinese
or chinese american
where something has changed about your
identity right
so um
you know if you were a nationalist you
know with the old government that just
fallen you know you were suddenly part
of this government that and part of this
world that has kind of was you know had
been this dominant power and is now kind
of
you know in control of this little
island you know taiwan which i think no
one ever heard of at the time i think
was still being called
mimosa by a lot of people and um you
know all of a sudden you're in exile
over there then of course over time you
know you're using a writing system that
is not no longer the dominant writing
system you're using a method of
romanization that is no longer the
dominant
method of romanization and
all these changes you know are all
traced back to
1949 you know the communists have won
and um
and for people in the amount you know
you can only imagine for my parents here
it was just unreal just as if you were
you know you were up you decided to do
graduate work in china you know and
while you were there
the united states fell
and your whole country is gone you know
your your neighborhood is go you know
everything
is upside down
nobody who you remember as being in
power is in power anymore they're all
kind of all collected in hawaii or
someplace you know you can only imagine
the shock so of course it's a very very
big date
glenn's in freeland michigan good
afternoon glenn you're on with author
gus jen
you know what i've got to push the
button
i i've done this once or twice before
glenn i apologize to you go ahead
hold on that's no problem thank you all
very much um and before i ask my
question i'd like to make a quick
comment if i could about
what miss gish was saying about um
68 and black and proud and all that i
can understand that with a certain
uh ethnic groups racial and ethnic
groups like blacks and irish and etc
chinese that have had a history of
historic discrimination in this nation
at this point though i think we'd all be
better off if everyone would just be a
human being and humble if you know what
i mean
um anyway my question is i was listening
to a talk by norman mailer some years
ago and he said that
when it comes to writing fiction the
worst person you can have as a narrator
is yourself it should just be somebody
you're comfortable with
my question for this guess would be how
much of fiction does
she think is really
basically autobio
autographical writing in that kind of
vein thanks very much thanks glenn
you know that is such an excellent
question you know people always think
especially if you've done a good job
people always do think that that is
really you right they think that um that
you know that um that it must be you of
course it's your job to make it seem
that way
but in fact just as normal miller said
the worst possible thing you could ever
do is to write a book you know where you
are the author you know you're the
narrator and it is your life people's
lives for so are just not very
interesting generally um i'm not
interesting enough to be a novel
they're not structured like a novel um
and um more importantly you know the
facts are often not as interesting as
the
the
facts told slant now i will say that you
know because i grew up with it would
seem to be in an
underrepresented world like so the world
that my father grew up in it was just
not on the page might you know
figures like me and scars down new york
or not on the page it was a very natural
thing for me to use those use those
worlds and the rules of those worlds um
to inform my fiction but that said you
know if you look at book like one of the
problems saying i am not mona i mean i'm
extremely not mona
and none of that happened
um
but the way that it is autobiographical
though i will say is that the tensions
in the book
are my tensions you know um gertrude
stein once said a really interesting
thing she said the the artist works by
locating the world in himself you know
we all wish that she had said herself of
course um but the fact of the matter is
that you know as a result of our contact
with the world um we have all developed
nerves you know and sensitivities
and you know it's it is my opinion that
if you can find one of those nerves
you will have a book but it will be much
more and it will be very personal
because they're your nerves
but it will far be far more interesting
than the facts of your life
and um so you know so you know the nerve
and mona is you know can a chinese
american girl turned jewish right and
like why is that funny you know i mean
it's really literally i used to um keep
these um pads of index cards um
these little spiral bound um notebooks
of intergroup and i would write ideas
down on them and then i would flip
through them years later to look for
ideas and i came to the car that said
mona turns jewish
and i started laughing
and then because i'm a novelist i
thought
what's that about why is that funny why
is you know irish-american girl turns
jewish that's not funny why is
chinese-american you know so what is the
difference between chinese being
chinese-american and jewish-american is
there something you know is there
something that's different about it and
and why
and um and surely i feel like god i
wonder if there's a nerve there and
that's why i'm laughing and sure enough
there was a big nerve there and it in
the book wrote itself but like i say so
that it is autobiographical in the sense
that um
that was my nerve
but it's not about that i'm not jewish
and
you know i've never really thought i've
never thought about converting to
judaism and um and all the facts of the
book are you know it's all made up but
you know it is it's it's autobiograph
biographical sense that it's a dream
that you're able to have you know and it
tells a kind of truth that is like the
truth in dreams right so it's not the
facts
it's truer than the facts really right
so you know many people have talked
about um assuming a mask it's kind of
the truth in masks
and there's a you know and that's a
that's a very wise thing you know in
fiction we assume a mask so that we can
we can get out of truth which is which
is truer than than kind of mere truth if
you will gish gen humor is a pretty
constant throughout your work yes yes
yes yes yes um you know i think that you
know people often where do you get this
from right and um
and i will say that you know my father
was just funny you know i think this is
these stories i tell you you know my
father tremendous sense of humor and
like i said things that other people
would be very you know upset about my
father always laughed about so they
thought everything was funny and of
course the nature of my material
lends itself to you being a
chinese-american you know and i think
what you're really seeing is that we
have all these constructs of the world
like with the cost of what a
chinese-american is and
that is so far off like you know like
the the gap between that and reality is
so large and when we when we laugh at
incongruity so because we have this
picture and it's wrong right so then
this chinese america everything she does
is kind of wrong so everything she does
is funny right
um
so to me the humor is good not only
because of course laughing is good for
you and um
we enjoy humor um but if there's
there's
you know there's a truth underneath it
too because every single time we laugh
at something that mona does
um
we laugh because we realize oh our
picture was wrong right
so so so it's you know it's a good kind
of humor i think it's a humor that makes
you think now this is a little of an old
quote that i'm going to read to you here
um but i want to get your reaction see
if it still stands up
from 1991 in the new york times my
family and i identified mostly with
white america which looking back was
partly wishful thinking partly racism
and partly an acknowledgement that
whatever else we did face at least we
did not have to contend with the legacy
of slavery god that is true
did i say that 1991 you did according to
the new york times
well i'm sure they got it right because
it's the new york times um well you know
that that would be true right i mean
because it would be very hard for me
then to
identify with asian americans you know
um but it's true that you know just in a
general kind of way
uh
you know like the jewish americans we
were kind of a middle minority right
and i always saw us you know was like
you know we were not we you know i might
we might have identified with the whites
growing up but of course it quickly
became apparent that we were not white
right
but um
but you know we were we were the
minority that was not african-american
and um and i will say you know you can
be black and also not be the minority of
this african-american like the
nigerian-americans are a great example
of um yes they are black but they also
do not have this legacy and i think that
there is a huge wall between all the
minorities that have lots to deal with i
mean there is plenty to deal with um
especially today um
and people who actually you know what i
mean who've been in america since they
get from the get-go
and who have been slaves i mean that's
just there's a huge
um divide
let's hear from patty in reedsville
wisconsin don't forget your button i've
got the button i've already pressed it
patty you're on book tv with author
gisjen
oh miss jen thank you for sharing uh the
subject my youngest nephew is adopted
from the philippines he came as an
infant uh he's a
beautiful wonderful
man in his 30s but he handled
discrimination with humor also and i had
a private conversation with him and i
said are you just covering he said no
patty it's just how you have to do it
and i am so thankful and appreciative
but i'd like to punch everybody's lights
out that does uh uh tease him a little
bit so god bless you thank you thank you
so much
you know the question you know this is
just like a little bit like what i was
saying about the jewish writers there's
no right or wrong you know so people
some people are very offended and really
angry and outspoken
and then they're all the people who can
kind of shrug and laugh um
i personally feel like just as a you
know as a matter of personal preference
i'm very happy that i'm the kind of
person who tends to shrug and laugh
um i mean i just think it's a it's a
it's an easier and happier way of being
but there's no right or wrong you know
so and i guess there's a way in which
i'm grateful to the people who are angry
and you know um
and kind of uh you know they're in the
philip roth you know angry mode
there's a way in which
they enable me
to laugh if you know what i mean um
maxine huh kingston someone said an
interesting thing about our writing
and she said that she cried so that i
could laugh
and there is a way in which that is also
true that she cried so that i could
laugh
all i can say is those of us who can
laugh
we must laugh and footnote and say and
thank you maxine huh kingston and we
must footnote and say you know thank you
all you know james ball baldwin all you
people who are angry um
we must acknowledge that like i say you
know we're all part of an ecosystem and
some of us are freed up really to be one
way by people who are another way
guess jen first of all where did the
gifts come from because that's not your
birth name yeah right
you know so i was born lily and jen um
and um
that was actually a very elegant name
that i had been given by my mother
because my chinese name was billian so
you can sound so it sounds like lillian
also they both have the same root they
both have lily as a root
and um so you know it's a very
elegant name um the lien
is um the lotus flower so you know so i
was named for the lotus that you know
has grows up out of the mud but opens up
pure
i'm sure i was as i opened up my mother
was thinking oh my god this is not the
pure white lily that i had in mind
um and so you know i'm going along with
this really very beautiful name um
but um
when i was a junior in high school i
went i'll wave oh oh i said oh wait okay
i was in junior high school and um i was
part of a creative writing group a
little club
and um this was run by name a guy named
flip khan
and
everybody got a nickname that was
related to their name because we're you
know we're in this kind of we're
inventing ourselves as arty types we're
going into
new york city to go watch cinema
as opposed to regular movies at home
and i had a friend whose last name was
houseman so they called her ae
and my name was lillian so they called
me gish after lillian gish i'm an
actress who moves movies i had never
seen so i really had no idea who lillian
gish was and had i known that she was in
movies like birth of the nation and i
would have been horrified but i didn't
know to be horrified but anyway it was
kind of just a nickname that a couple
people use and in really very limited
circumstances
until i went away
in the summer to an archaeological dig
in clarion pennsylvania
and you know
it was you know i'm away from home um
there was a hurricane so um the building
had just been hit by lightning and so
our our electricity was out
and so we're going around a circle by
candlelight and we're you know we're
we're introducing ourselves
and they got to me and with no
premeditation whatsoever
i introduced myself as gish jen like i
don't know why you know so i don't know
what came over me it just popped out
and um today i know that the self-naming
is something that a lot of writers do
you know jamaican kid you know tennessee
williams you know it's everywhere right
mark twain um at the time i didn't know
that this business of self-naming is
very highly associated with going on to
be a writer
um but i will say
that um that summer you know the idea of
self-invention it was very much on my
mind as that you know gishgen did all
these things that lily and jen never did
like liam jenn was a nice girl
gishgen was like
you know propping the windows open at
night and you know sneaking in animal
hours and and just in general kind of
carrying on with the kind of freedom i
will say kind of an american freedom
um that lily and jen did not have you
know that's and i will say over the
years like you know gishen even has a
different handwriting than lily and jen
lilly and jen is still using the palmer
method from from you know from my
catholic school upbringing uh gishgen is
a completely different thing um and um
what's so interesting to me is like so
the question is like in the middle of
the night now if there was some kind of
emergency and i had to write one note
before i was
dashing out the door which handwriting
would it be
and the answer is the gish gen i think i
i really can only write one thing
in my old handwriting now um and that is
my name because i saw my checks with
that name but except for signing my
checks i do not use that script at all
it's completely gone i can see like if i
look at things from when i was in grade
school i can see it
but i i can't do i literally can't do it
anymore it's so interesting right so i
really have become the kind of this
other person
and um
yeah and i will say you know my very
first story a building up that i was
talking about i wrote in iowa um was
published into lily and jen
and all my friends said who's she
and as soon as they said i said oh my
god that's so right it's like the person
who writes these stories
is not lee and jen the person who writes
the stories is kish jen
there it is the only question really
left is like why do i not just change
all my papers i guess this is kind of a
pain
let's hear from dorothy in buffalo new
york hi dorothy
hi
uh uh this follows uh this question
follows really well with what she just
said i'm very interested in
uh the technical aspects of her writing
does she need to have a certain
environment
how does she get her ideas
where does she write does she write
every day
etc
before you leave us though dorothy are
you a writer are you a writer no i'm no
i'm no i'm not no i'm not but are you an
aspiring writer
no i'm not no uh but i i enjoy reading
good writers and who are some of your
favorite authors
um
well i have to say that one of my
favorites is
i love wuthering heights
and
well guess jen has been described as a
writer's writer and she's won many
awards for her writing so to answer
dorothy's questions well you know
everybody is always interested in these
things and um
and um let's see so i
write as often as i can um i you know so
i don't have a set schedule and if left
to my druthers i will write
15 hours a day um if i didn't have to
sleep i would i mean i wish i didn't
have to sleep you know um partly because
you know because of the way that i write
as i've described because it is kind of
dreamlike um the one thing that you do
not like as a writer is interruptions
you know because it's
a dream is so easy when you're in it and
as soon as you leave it it disappears on
you so you know you do not want to be
interrupted
and like i said if i didn't have to
sleep i wouldn't sleep but i do have to
sleep
um
it is very hard on your back you know
that you sit there
um so long so you know the one thing
that i do do is i have yoga video tapes
and so i will make myself get up three
times a day to do some yoga just so that
i don't fall apart um but aside from
yoga i you know i don't want to talk to
anybody i'm you know i'm actually a very
social person but when i'm writing i
didn't want to talk to anyone um
and uh i do use a computer i was um an
early
adopter of the computer because my
husband was an apple computer so unlike
many writers after that time you know i
typed even though you know many people
sort of feel like you know real writers
write by hand
um i've never been able to write my read
my own handwriting you know this might
be related to the lillian gish thing um
i can barely read my own handwriting um
and i can't
i can't write as fast as i think
so i had always been a typist um
but you know because my husband was it
was an apple in the early days i had
access some of the early computers um so
um what would happen is you know that
people would be frustrated and when they
would solder everything together the
engineers would give this machine that
was really useless um to my husband my
husband would bring it home and so you
know i would write on these early
machines the early lisa the early
macintosh um and which i actually found
wonderful i actually wrote a little
piece about this when um steve jobs
died which is in the
new york times sunday review um you know
about what was the title uh muse is a i
don't remember you know they make up the
titles the writers don't give the titles
i'm using my muse was an apple computer
news app yeah there was something nice
about the computer that had that little
blink
green light it was just like you know
talk to me talk to me i'm waiting for
the next word i'm waiting for the next
word so i actually liked using the
computer but like i said back in those
days there was kind of a stigma against
it so those of us who had who had gone
into using a computer would often do
something to our managers to make it
look like they've been hand typed like
you put a little white out on them or
something um because i guess it was just
this feeling that somehow it was a
machine and that was a bad thing um but
like i said i found it very liberating
and
i will say too that in a general kind of
way you know
we've seen you know huge diversity in
our writing you know last few decades um
and i think one of the reasons is
because of the computer you know for
those of those of us for instance who
just you over the typewriter you had to
find some place where people didn't mind
the noise of your typing that meant that
you couldn't really type all night
because we were bothering people the
computer type online nobody knows it's
really great
also for those of us you know i think in
the early days of course tolstoy
famously had his wife retyping
everything everybody and everybody you
know often to back off you know all
these writers had you know somebody to
help clean up their manuscripts all of a
sudden you can clean up your own
manuscript so not only were you not the
assistant to some great writer um
but um you did not you did not yourself
require uh
an assistant so you know to me the
computer you know has just been an
unbelievable gift what about the loss of
early drafts
well there is there is that and i i
think that scholars don't like it you
know because we just you ever print out
your early drafts so you you know
with some of my
typical american i think i probably
saved some of the early dress now i just
feel like oh my god it's like so much
paper you know and i'm sure that
scholars will not like that um but of
course you know the scholars have this
view that kind of there's something in
those first drafts as they're coming out
that is more authentic
you know but the writers don't like this
well why do we write the books if the
early you know the early drafts are or
just
you know they're just like
i know you know iowa we used to say that
there's that one school of thought about
how to write it was the was that you
know you do everything perfectly first
we're gonna write out right you know
from the get-go but there's another
school which we used to call barf and
polish you know which is it you just
kind of write anything
and then you look at what you have and
then you try to find the book in it so
to me it's like it's just barf and
polish it's like it's not a book so why
do you want this early stuff
and um
it's it's it's not a book and also if
you had the feeling that someone was
going to look at it you couldn't barf
properly you know you have to be very
unself-conscious you know so um like i
say i think scholars look at it
differently um you know there's a really
so interesting there's been a real um
interest in things like um you know
re-ethnicizing uh kafka you know so
kafka his early drafts are in
improv you know his native frog german
um and then he would clean them up into
kind of high german for publication and
that's how he wanted them right um but
because there's so much interest in this
kind of original self which in this case
is also an ethnic self which they feel
to be
kind of so more really kafka than his
the self that he they're the books that
he made um there's this desire to go
back to
you know like you know the prague german
he would have been horrified and i'm on
i'm on his side i'm on his side that's
like you know what he he was making
something and there's a way in which you
know by sort of saying well this earlier
thing is kind of you know is um
in some ways greater or more real or
more more authentic i think you have a
very mistaken idea about what the
authenticity even really is and i say
we like those final drafts
every semicolon in place
[Laughter]
another quote from gis gen in the new
york times there is never enough time
for writing every moment spent in one's
real life
is a moment missed in one's writing life
and vice versa it's so true these things
are in competition your real life and
your writing life you know and um i you
know i wrote those pieces about trying
to quit writing because i felt like it
was you know like i was i mean i was
trying to quit and that you know when
you quit though you just realize like oh
my god you know your writing life is so
much richer
in some ways than you really i mean look
i like real life too you know but to me
i have to say that you know i do not
like this business of feeling like
they're in conflict and i have to choose
i mean if i could change the world um i
would change the world so that i could
have like my real life 24 hours a day
and my writing life 24 hours a day do
you mean like i don't like it but
you do have to pick you still keep your
office separate from your home yes i've
never been able to work in my house
and um you have kids
yeah i have kids but my kids my youngest
one has left the house now so it's kind
of interesting um you could sort of see
up to now and i do have often
recommended recommended this to young
writers that they should get an office
outside of the house you know even if
it's you know what i mean and you can
often arrange to rent someone's room for
50 50 a month it doesn't have to be a
lot of money but the separation if you
have little children it can be critical
but um for me though it's partly related
to children but i think this is also
related to um you know a lot of things
we're talking about you know what it
meant to be a daughter of immigrants
inventing this second self i mean i
think there is a way in which being at
home um tends to kind of reinforce the
self of
obligations you know i need to do this i
need to do that you know all the the
duty bound self um and that's important
the responsible self and you know it's
important i'm in favor of adults being
responsible
but writing is not responsible it's not
a responsible activity and you cannot be
doing it with responsibility everywhere
so i think there's a way in which i am
just trying to get away from that world
into this arena where i can just play um
and that's why i have to remove myself
to another space now we have spent most
of this first hour talking about guest
gen as a writer as a person some of the
structure around her life
we're going to spend the next two hours
delving into her books a little more
deeply but let's hear from karen calling
in from north andover massachusetts hi
karen
oh hi good afternoon this is wonderful
um i would like to ask if
you have any
interest in poetry
i'm a poet laureate of my town
in massachusetts and did you ever do
poetry yourself and
do you know of
any poet's laureate
idea in in the asian culture as we have
in you know europe has them i
i don't know if japan or china or
those countries have
um
designated specific poets laureate
um over the years i know of basho and
japan and some other um wonderful poets
but i just wondered if there's a
definite demarcation that you would be
called a laureate karen what is it
what is it about poetry for you
well poetry to me
i say that
when you're um uh when a child is in
utero
you are hearing a flow
constantly of sounds within your
mother's womb and
i feel that the flow of writing if it's
done well even
a novel
if it's a poe
prose poetry
you're pulled into it without even
knowing
why it's so good to read this book
it's because it's written in a poetic
style
and it it flows that's why we love music
i believe music's the first
art we ever heard
and started to try to copy
and i believe that poetry flows out of
music
thank you ma'am
thank you i so agree thank you so much
for your call um first of all let me say
i think it's just wonderful that you are
the poet laureate of north andover and
um they're very lucky to have you um
i think that you are absolutely right
about
you know
this goes back to kind of like you know
is your work autobiographical and is it
just the facts i mean the fact the
matter is we do not write read the facts
we read for the melody right we meet we
read for the music of the words and you
are absolutely right there's something
about it which um of course we're
interested in the meaning of the words i
mean you know
that absolutely matters
but we're really interested in all you
know there's a pre-verbal kind of part
of this which you're you know you're
right that probably goes in back to our
um our experiences in utero
and um and that is easily as important
if not more important
than the actual you know the meanings of
the words you know the answer is it's
this is not this is not necessarion the
way that fiction works you know the
uncanny way um that fiction and poetry
work um is it goes back to something
deeper than our rational thinking selves
and you know often when people
even in in
the novel writing world you know when
we're looking at something and there's
something we feel
yeah that we feel that things are mosaic
um what we're saying is it doesn't sing
you know and if it doesn't sing there is
a problem um and um
yeah it's interesting um one of the one
of the writers i talk about grace paley
you know to talk about her trouble and
the novel she tried to write a novel and
she said the trouble with her novel was
that she was it was prosaic and it was
it was pedestrian and so she never she
didn't pursue the novel she just
couldn't keep up her singing in the long
form for whatever reason
um to get to your earlier questions um i
did come out of poetry so my very first
writing was for robert fitzgerald's
class and versification um they were all
poems i loved writing poems
i did take all the writing workshops
that i took as an undergraduate were
poetry writing workshops they were not
in they were not in the novel um but it
was sort of interesting even then if you
looked at my poems um a lot of them were
narrative you know i wrote narrative
poems so you know it's kind of i still
love poetry um maybe in some
you know in some dream life i would be a
poet uh maxine hunt kingston you may
know um this kind of graduated
from the world of um of narrative to the
world of poetry um grace paley did the
same thing later in life
um she has just just very famously said
you know i was like your poetry writing
is great you could do it your whole life
which is true i think there's just
something about the you know the
lyricism you know this kind of this pure
expression of something um
without having to worry about getting
the reader through the pages um you're
so liberating and wonderful it's kind of
liberation that i at least associate
with being older you know kind of being
beyond it all um so maybe i'll go back
to poetry when i finally have attained
that state of enlightenment um as for
whether there were poetry um laureates
in china not to my knowledge you know
because china you know greatly esteems
especially the chang dynasty poets um
and um every child can re recite certain
poems and so poetry is very much alive
in china really much better established
tradition than the novel tradition in
china um but to the best of my knowledge
i don't think they do have um poet
laureates um if i'm if i'm wrong about
that if i discover that you know they do
i will definitely post it on facebook
so you can watch for the post but i i
don't think that they do
your last novel
world in town
describe hattie
harry kuhn well honey kong is the you
know is a descendant of
missionaries on one side of her family
and um confucius on the other side so
she's kind of a hybrid kind of like me
she's not me
um but you can sort of see why i would
have um an interest some in someone like
her sure she is an immigrant of yours
i love harry kong
i do i do and all her complexity and her
humility
um and um
you know there's just a way in which you
know and she's the on you know the fact
that she's 68 and she's still growing
and searching and pushing and
and and also trying to make the world a
better place you know um
so i did have middlemarch a little bit
in my mind as i was writing that book so
you can see a little bit of the dorothea
brook influence on her um
i think a little bit i mean i'm sort of
saying is this an influence she's not
dorothy or book reincarnated or anything
like that
um but you know there she is she is um
but she also i think redefines that kind
of what an immigrant can bring to
america you know so so she is more than
a person with her noses plus to the
glass she's a person whose nose has been
pressed to the glass
and um who has learned some things that
way and has things to give back to
america um so she is not just like she's
not just formed by america she's forming
america right she's forming this town
um and um
she is you know as you know she she
isn't you know she's she complicates our
ideas about what it means to american be
american in the sense that christian her
mother was american so she was american
before she came to america even though
she was born and raised in china right
so um so she's you know she's a
complicated woman um she's a woman as
you know um who who lived with an
american family uh when she first came
here and um he was very marked by that
experience
she there's a way in which she realizes
that she can never become part of that
family and i don't want to give away the
end but of course but she does in the
end
on her own terms
and maybe that's the most important part
of of that book which so this is a book
in which we see somebody
a simile but all
you know she is made by america but she
is remaking america and it's finally
about claiming her place
in this country
on her own terms
what does she look like
oh that's a good question i know
you probably remember better than but
that i don't i mean in your mind's eye
what does she look like well you know
because i wrote that book a time ago but
you know i see i see her as you know
having kind of you know the half-half
look that my children have i will say
you know so she has black hair do you
mean but she's you know she's erasing
a mary asian we would say today
how long were you working that book
stylistically first of all stylistically
is that book different
than some of your other novels well i
think all my novels
each novel is different from the others
right so typical american
um
you know five parts you can see the
influence of shakespeare in that you
know i mean i mean it's almost you know
what i mean you can see i'm still using
that five part five act um play
structure right
um
um by mona i've thrown that out you know
the corset is off
and it's much more kind of a
freewheeling here i am you can see the
influence of roth and bellow well you
can see augie march and jimmy kind of
bella you know and rothino kind of just
like i'm just letting it rip you know
and and that's the point um is that you
know it's like uh what that would say
like an unfurling right it's a very
different thing um
the love wife you know um you have a you
know that's a a book i i started right
now right at 9 11. there's a lot of
thought that we needed a different kind
of novel to deal with our new reality
and so you can see big formal invention
where you have people just kind of
talking on the page but also
very very very um
much interested in this being poly
polyphonic right there being lots of
voices everybody gets to talk it was
kind of hyper democratic for a novel you
know
everybody gets a talk um this is not a
play where they're they're they all are
um
if this is not a play where they're you
know they're in you know in a single
action and just um they have dif they're
just different characters now they're
all
narrating you know
you know they're they're all narrating
and like i say you can sort of see this
kind of interest in um in a new kind of
um
novel to kind of to grapple with a new
reality um and of course the novel does
ask me questions by the end um
you know
can america really be the hospitable
place that it has been you know can we
really live up to this ideal that we've
had of of a nation that is um
a matter of constant rather than decent
that's all on the matter all you know
that's all a matter of voluntary um
adherence to certain ideals is that
enough for our nation so so there's a
way in which the family in the love life
is a metaphor for america and you know
the question mark over that family you
know the book ends like um the day
before 9 11. the question mark over that
family is the question mark over america
and i will say of course um
you know i've started the book in 2000
and you know right on 9 11 published in
2004 and of course a lot of the
questions that i raised there
you know are questions that we have
today um and then world it's a world in
town again a departure
and again
a book where many people are narrating
um there is a suggestion that um because
we have kind of one thing going on but
also these insertions it's almost like a
series uh in my mind
there's a sense that kind of they're you
know you're you're getting these stories
but that there are all these other an
infinite number of other stories that
could also be in this book they just
wouldn't all fit you know you know i
mean so there's a way in which i do have
a enough true story that you feel like
it's one story but you do also feel like
i hope
that um that the boundary around the
novel is uh not a solid thing but a
permeable thing you know so this is this
is a selection of reality but a little
bit the way i was talking about that as
i'm
i laugh but i must acknowledge that i
laugh because maxine constance kingston
cried
um there is a way in which this book is
we have this book but we must
acknowledge that there are other
realities
that kind of enabled this book to be
here and that are not are not part of
this book does that make sense
jen did you know how this book was gonna
end when you started it no of course not
and and um and this goes back to the the
caller who asked about process um i
never know where i'm going um
that is because you know more than
anything else we want our novels we want
our fiction to live
and floundering o'connor says that you
know the author's not surprised no one
else is going to be surprised either you
know so there's a way in which
of course you're kind of driving but
you're you've got to be open to
wherever you might go
you know and like i say i think that you
know the the whole thing about the novel
the reason so interesting is because you
don't know
you not only do you not know where your
book is going to be you don't know what
writing this book is going to do to you
as a person
and whether you are going to be the same
person who started the book by the end
of the book and i would say actually
ideally ideally you are not the same
person
as you were at the beginning of the book
um now it's a part of part of my writing
this way of really not knowing the end
as opposed to having an outline is that
you know i came out of the short story
and that's how i that's kind of just how
i knew to write you know
i just knew that you'd start out with a
feeling or something or nerve and you
just followed the nerve out and that's
what i had learned from the short story
so i still did that you know in the
longer form
but it's also true what i notice is even
when i wrote nonfiction i know that's
not the subject of your show but if i
may sneak this in there
i did it the same way and why did i do
it the same way well one of the reasons
is that i'm writing on a book for
often
three four five years
i have to be interested too you know i
mean and honestly having an outline and
executing it is not interesting you know
it's got to be an adventure for me as
well
so um so that i i i guess that's the
sort of say i like it that i don't know
where i'm going i like it that the
writing is making that i it's making me
the author as i go along and i certainly
like it that i don't know where i'm
going
and i like the surprise when finally i
have actually gotten someplace you know
which i can only hope to help
i really am going to
but in truth until that last page i
myself don't know
so the fact that hattie
is a descendant of confucius
and of missionary american parents
is that just straight up east-west
no it's not straight off east-west
because it's more complicated than that
i hope that you get that from the book
you know
no it's not it's not that simple um it
is interesting that she has religion on
both sides though right
and you know one of the many things that
i wanted to do with this ends up at the
unitarian church yeah
um
you know
there is a way in which you know you
know when people write about um you know
america or you know i mean it's like if
you're going to write a novel with asian
americans in it well then it's about
ethnicity right well i'm thinking but
but religion is so important you know i
mean it's kind of like so you know so i
wanted to write a book where you have as
an asian american but she has
she also is very much formed by her
religions
plural in this case right
and um and i think that that you know
that is that's the truth i mean the
truth is that you know it's not only
about you know we eat certain foods and
therefore we are ex you know we eat in
certain foods
in a certain way and also we eat other
foods and also we have religious
traditions that have been very important
to us
whether they are
you know whether they're authentically
chinese or not in other words so you
know it's kind of like you sort of say
that confucianism is her real self but
christianity is her real self also you
know me and also
this part of america so when i'm adding
this kind of if you imagine this
ethnic book to the library of america
well you can call it an ethnic book but
but it's you know it's also expanding
our idea of what an ethnic book is right
so an ethnic book is also a book that is
about america which is also about
fundamentalism globalization you know
um you know
not you know the changing you know
farming practices you know everything um
they're not they're not at odds you know
i mean that is what an ethnic novel is
right
where is world in town filed in a
bookstore or at a library under gen
[Laughter]
you know what i meant
you're gonna make me say it is it under
ethnic studies or is it under
american
history you know you know i think that i
think it gets hot in both and that's
what i you know what i mean and that's
what that's my answer right
um i mean in the sense that you know
uh yeah no
hard to say where to place it hard to
say replace it um um from the very
beginning you could sort of see mono you
know i've always had this feeling of
whenever you feel that there's like a
box like an ethnic box you know other
people are just like oh my god i'm so
offended that i'm not you know that they
shovel us this way this way you know and
my idea is that you know you need to
blow that box up you know i mean that's
our job right so um
so yeah no i feel like okay so you know
as soon as you have the feeling like we
could put it here but hmm and we could
here put it here but
then i feel like i'm happy
because you know and maybe this is kind
of the difference you know the
difference between fiction non-fiction i
know this is a little bit too broad
maybe but in a general kind of way
you know
we are about you know flannery economy
is say mystery and manners but the
mystery part is that it was very
important so you know when you get all
the manners right that's important right
you know these are the mores of our time
um just like you know when when when
jane austen says you know it's the truth
universally acknowledged single men a
single man in possession of a good
fortune must be a wonderful wife right
we need to know what the what the word
what the rules are in our world you know
just like that i grew up with you know
is a truth universally acknowledged that
uh you know a young woman and you know
in possession of good grades must go to
medical school right
it's our job to know what those rules
are and to get them down and to say
this is the world as we humans have
constructed it at this time right and
that is a part of our job
but the other part of our job
is to suggest really
the huge mystery on
below that right and um that it is co it
is our job not to simplify but to
complicate
to complicate complicate complicate you
might ask me why do you want to do that
why do you want to do that
very good
one of the reasons it's just like it is
just like is truth universally
acknowledged and the fact is we are busy
making you know our brains we make
all these categories right um you know
we you know chinese-american you know
way women men you know and
they
serve us up to a point
but they always they're always a little
bit out of date right they're always a
little behind reality is changing like
look at the word woman oh my god you
know i mean so out of date and it's our
job to suggest you know what it's really
more complicated to get those things to
kind of dissolve a little bit so that
they can be reformed you know society
can renew and actually answer to the
very complicated beings that we actually
are
so we want to complicate people's views
we don't want to just reinscribe like
you know what i mean oh you know what a
woman is well here's a funny thing
that's going to reinforce your idea
about what woman is well that's really
important that's not our job as artists
now our job is to say you thought you
knew what a woman is
but is that what a woman is anymore do
you mean and it's also to maybe to open
the path to realizing down the line
you know we don't we don't know what a
woman will be in 50 years you know so
that's a way in which it kind of
reinstalls the kind of humility but like
i said we you know we need all these
categories we cannot negotiate the world
but we need to have a kind of humility
about them and we need to understand
that beyond them
are humans who are just really
unfathomably deep and mysterious
and it is our job as writers to
endlessly really kind of
remind people you know that we tend to
make kind of stick figures out of
reality we make you know we make kind of
icons or whatever out of people
but that's not who they are those are
just our our representations of them
that we use for our purposes to get
through our day
it's not it's not the truth the truth is
like i say
way deeper way more complicated
way more mysterious well guess jen at
some point you had to say
in your head or sitting in your room by
yourself
okay this story is going to take place
in maine
and there's going to be this
asian-american protagonist there's going
to be this cambodian family there's
going to be this waspy ex-lover there's
going to be cell phone towers there's
going to be
ginny the fundamentalist christian
how do you plot all that out
into a
book about the u.s
well you know
of course that's why it takes me so long
i mean it's not like i sit there and say
oh i know you know but um you know often
just as i did with kind of with like
scarsdale scars hill or you know kind of
you know i often will look at i just
have certain materials at hand like
they're right here you know and no one's
ever used them you know so i will just
start with them in this case you know i
do spend a lot of time in northern
vermont
and um that meant that ev you know
driving up i would drive by these
churches that had these big crosses on
them it's like what are these churches
and why doesn't anybody write about them
right because i don't see them in any
you know i don't see them actually in
our literature right
and um and you know and then of course
you can't be there for five minutes but
realize like oh no one is going to the
churches on the green anymore but wait a
minute that's that's what that's the
world that updike wrote about right but
what i see is all these churches in the
green are empty and every single one of
them is struggling and they don't know
what to do
where all the people have gone they've
all gone from the churches on the green
into these
churches with the with the big crosses
like what is going on right
so it's kind of like and so if you're
gonna you know just so you know you can
sort of see it's just like it's right
there in front of me so i said oh
who are these people you know i actually
went did a lot of research for that book
and i did go
um
i um
you know i would visit these churches
and of course in the beginning i was
worried that they would realize that i
was a spy right um but it was so
interesting did you feel like a spy of
course i was a spy okay that's when i'm
there i'm taking notes that's why i'm
there i want to know you know what are
they seeing why you know what's
different about this you know why why
are people going to these churches and
you know why have they left the other
church and um
that's very funny though but there's
always something that you don't know so
just when you're thinking you know i'm
going to be conspicuous because the way
i look right you know it was very funny
the first church they said oh are you
korean and the light went out like
they're all going to think i'm korean
so i just said sure yes
and then it was of course you know then
you're one of us like we know who you
are you are a korean christian that's
why you're here welcome and i'm
basically that's how i got into all
these churches to go watch what went on
and i also had you know i also had a
friend at divinity school at harvard who
was um
and she also took me around some of
these churches so that i can go see
um you know you know firsthand you know
what you know what are they saying you
know what are these retreats like i
write about one of these retreats you
know what the retreat's like uh what you
know what are the preachers like you
know and very importantly
why are people listening to them
and you know what is it you know what is
it that is driving people
to these preachers and to these churches
and of course and i will say that the
same things that drive ginny
in you know to become fundamentalist
are the same things that you know drove
many people to to vote for donald trump
right um it's the same thing you know
they feel you know it's funny people say
oh they're angry it's like they're not
just angry they feel
dispossessed you know so um
you know this this book is a book in
which you know many people are displaced
i mean patty is displaced um but one of
my own revelations of course she's
displaced but they're also displaced you
know there is a you know the thing that
she knows which is like what it means to
be radically displaced
they have been displaced literally
they've lost their farms you know
literally they've lost you know with the
farm within genesis case
um but the whole legacy that goes with
that farm i mean that that is the farm
is a family it's been there for
generations and then all of a sudden
they've got to compete with you know
with beef from argentina do you mean
like globalization is hit them really
hard
you know um all of a sudden there are
you know these developments all around
the edges of this of the you know that
they're having to all the big farms are
being nibbled away at the edges they've
got to sell off the land
and you know it's just like for them to
solve the land
that is them you know what they say and
so they feel in this way in which you
know she's so angry
at what has happened to her family and
her family's farm she is so radically
dispossessed
that suddenly somebody who had been kind
of a you know kind of a um you know a
christian but kind of maybe a more
moderate kind of christian
suddenly right we see the fundamentalist
edge you know the um within the
evangelical um community i will say that
you know in the press all the time you
hear evangelicals and fundamentalists
lumped together but actually one thing
that i learned very quickly um if you
said to them something something
something and they would the
evangelicals will talk about the
fundamentals like they're very different
um and they will say evangelical the
evangelicals will say a fundamental
assistant evangelical
evangelical was really angry
you know i mean and it's so interesting
because like i say in the press you hear
them love together but they don't lump
themselves together at all
um
and um and and that's exactly what
happens
to jenny because that's how i talk to
people like oh i see what happens you
know
they lose their farm they're
really angry and then all of a sudden
the things that they're hearing in this
other kind of church you know this is
not the methodist orgies and not the
presbyterian you know they're hearing
this other kind of narrative and that
narrative is a big
angry you know what i mean
uh you know end of the world you know
like this world you are going to burn
type narrative
just it just embodies everything that
they feel
but one of the things i noted in that
book is that you don't just even if you
were a spy in your in your
research
it's not a completely negative portrayal
i mean you're giving it's very
sympathetic yeah yeah well that's my job
too i mean i think you know this is the
humility part
you know it's like it's not that it's
not the writer's job to judge
you know
it is um because
i guess you know there's a way
especially since you know i what i what
i saw was that
yeah they're just displaced just like
annie
you know in some ways um hattie is
better equipped you know she's more
radically displaced you might say
but in some ways um hattie is better
equipped to deal with the displacement
than they are you know maybe because
she's officially displaced like
everybody can see that she's displayed
you know clearly she's displaced where
they're displaced in a kind of more
invisible way so that people are not as
you know i mean they're not as um
uh no one says oh of course you're angry
you're just you've been displaced you
don't say
you know you don't have an official name
like refugee or immigrant or something
like that where you understand oh i see
i've been radically displaced
you talk about hattie she's been
swimming for the shore for 50 years yeah
yeah yeah it is it's sympathetic to her
too
and um and i do think that in in in some
you know
to be an immigrant
it's not like you arrived in the united
states and three years later eurovision
lane is over
she's been swimming her whole life for a
sense of place and a replacement for the
home
that she lost and um
yeah i i have tremendous sympathy what i
what i see is it it never ends the
immigration because
at every stage everything is different
you know including you know my father
died though what are the rituals now
you know what do you do you know
whatever you did for your father in
china well you can't even do that here
you know i mean like where are you going
to get the buddhist monks to come and
sing you know
where they gonna come from the answer is
the rituals are all disrupted
and um
yeah in china you know they would have
had like a register in the family altar
with people's names on them and you know
kind of people you know so then when
people came to pray they would pray for
the people who had died interestingly
they only keep it's like the chinese
family book
no this is just the on the on the family
altar they would have something like
this but interestingly that your your
name only stays on this list for five
years and then it's done
i think so but you're not you're not on
the active morning list anymore but um
but you know there's no family alter so
where would my father's name go so that
we could mourn him do you mean in other
words and then where are the rituals
where people will come of course
and remember him
um
where is the grave sweeping day where we
would go and sweep this grave well
there's no great you know in other words
so that even though it would seem like
my mother had been here for 50 years
already
she's still an immigrant were like well
what now you know i mean like
you know as if she didn't need further
reminding
that her whole world was gone you know
it's like you know it's you know
everything is you is you know you have
to kind of learn about how it all works
um all over again with every single
stage of life so it kind of never ends
and um
like i say you know once you've gotten
your english under control and so on
that's it's it's that that's not the end
of it at all it goes on for a long long
long time
i have left these callers on hold for
way too long i apologize greg
ralla missouri please go ahead
hi miss jen
hi
i had i had uh a
question
uh in reading a few academic articles uh
recently i came across it looked like
this the same issue was raised in in
them and if i could read one sentence
and if you could shed some light on what
the author is uh lee wong and
he or she says quote
since the 1970s the the famous or say
infamous
debate between the incendiary frank chen
and maxine hong kingston
toward the authentic representation of
chinese culture
i was just wondering what i i wasn't
clear what
what that what that um issue was what
that was all about yes yeah well you
know that was in the very very early
days of asian american literature um
maxine
conkington of course was
the iconic figure
and um
frank chin who was really a very minor
figure and whose name we probably would
not know today except that he attacked
maxine khan kingston so viciously and um
it was not only maxine actually he also
uh attacked uh like figures like jade
snow wong i think he and his cronies um
actually you know attacked jade snow
wong on stage to the point where she
started crying on stage it was really a
terrible thing um but he saw them as all
writing what he thought was kind of
white christian um
um
work that was meant to pander he thought
to the you know to the uh caucasian
audience um i think that you know to be
fair you know we do live in america
where most people are caucasian you know
so if we do things like explain chinese
phrases um
well you know if you're going to write
your novel in chinese and who's going to
read it you know you're living in
america i mean it's you know obviously
there is some speaking to the um the
audience um but i think in particular i
think that he really didn't like it that
um
that that she had taken this myth of
mulan you know this this woman warrior
and made her into this kind of feminist
uh uh figure
which is not how he read it all so he
felt the whole thing was kind of
inauthentic um and of course at the
heart of it is the question of whether
you can take
you know a traditional figure
and make it into something for your own
purposes
and you know
today i think looking at it as like
clearly she was within her rights
i mean we have figures like um
[Music]
el doctoro has taken like any number
of historical figures and put them in
his work um you know look you may not
like the way that you know what what um
the conclusions that
that uh leo tolstoy comes to about the
the you know the napoleonic wars and you
know whether napoleon was responsible
for it or not you know you you may
differ from his opinion but he is within
his rights um in presenting it that way
and i to me i think the real issue is
that you know
is that because there were so few asian
americans at the time um rather than
seeing her version of the mulan story as
her version of the mulan story like
clearly
you know we have other sources on the
nepali napoleonic wars we have other
sources on you know these various
historic figures
um i think that because there were so
few sources i think um
frank chin was probably afraid that this
would be the only understanding that
anyone would ever have of mulan and that
it was quote unquote not the authentic
um uh version
you know
what was very interesting to me is that
you know many years later of course um
the movie mulan came out and um you know
the question of course was you know are
we gonna have big protests over the way
that mulan has been handled in that
movie um and interestingly there were no
protests over the movie um and there
were no person protests on them over the
movie i think because that moment had
had passed the moment when
one movie or one book would seem to kind
of represent the whole truth about mulan
nobody thought that anymore you know so
what i see what i think is that you know
this whole um
and you know this this whole difficulty
that frank chin had with
with maxine was really just some was
kind of a byproduct of the time that
they were in and the fact that there
were so so so few um asian americans and
certainly very very very few
representations of any kind and i will
say uh to this day i i feel um
i think the frank chen had a point um
but i do wish that he had attacked with
less viciousness um maxine conkingson is
the most peaceable creature imaginable
and the whole idea that he made her lose
sleep for even a nanosecond i have to
say makes me pretty mad
you know
in one google search
that i did of you
at
whatever page i was on you may also
enjoy
maxine hong kingston and amy tan
um i said that no no no that was a
search i did and that's what came up in
the uh the ai the artificial
intelligence or the algorithm whatever
it was that's what came up yeah well you
know we all kind of get grouped together
even though like and i think i say you
know same way the jewish american
writers that you know you can group them
together to me it just highlights the
differences
right i mean in other words i think it's
you know to me as soon as you put them
together like oh my god you know like
how else could you put you know what i
mean like cynthia ozek in the same
category as phil i mean it's kind of it
it just kind of it feels like a
historical accident because they're
they're um
their sensibilities are so different and
of course we writers are nothing if we
are not our sensibilities right i mean
that's it that's i guess what i'm trying
to say about frank chin is that you know
mexican kingston has a sensibility she's
filtering the world that's why she's an
author we want her to filter the world
we want her to filter chinese tradition
or you know you name it um and we read
them because
of the way that they're filtering right
um and
anyway but but you know i think to me
you know as soon as you lump me and
maxine and kingston and amy chan are all
one group i think what you mostly see is
wow three people who all have black hair
or black hair that's turned to white
hair or whatever you know um
three people who are sort of related
being from
you know a generation ago or so or more
to you know another part of the world
where there are a billion people by the
way so they're not so alike um and when
we look at their work we see very very
very very different things i mean i
think that you mostly see um how
uninterchangeable we are
as you write in world in town
the eyes are a sea of memory
[ __ ] one's world view
steve palm bay florida please go ahead
you're on with author and novelist gish
jim
thank you guys and peter
i'm just reminded from the first hour
of the remark about isolating authors
and uh i tell you a a short humorous
event my parents were just starting out
as young professors at about holyoke
and one day they heard a knock at the
door and they opened and looked out saw
nothing looked down and there were two
little children and they looked up and
said
we're hungry our parents write
and that's been told in my family for
years
we're hungry our parents write
w-r-i-t-e
oh that is really funny
is that is it tough to be successful as
a writer of course
of course well if you think about the
nature of what we do you know it's kind
of this whole idea that writers of
course are starved you know there's some
truth to it and the reason there's a
truth to it is because we're always
because as i sort of said we're trying
to get people to look past
their convenient realities you know so
of course that's uncomfortable you know
as you as soon as you say well is a
woman really what you think a woman is
of course i feel really uncomfortable
and lo and behold people don't want to
pay you to do that you know
so you know so they're you know because
you are kind of on the cutting edge of
society and of course you're going to
focus on especially on the things that
are a little bit not right right so
you know your ideas about asian
americans your ideas about women your
ideas about african-americans you know
fill in the blank
um
capitalism you know religion
you know because we're because we are
doing that um
you know it's it's not a path to
popularity
now sometimes you can do it and somehow
even though you've done this really
very kind of
of subversive thing uh sometimes people
it will be just the kind of subversion
that people are ready for and then
they'll buy a lot of copies of your book
really it's kind of a surprise right
when philip roth wrote you know
portnoy's complaint i mean i mean i
don't know if he realized it was going
to be this huge you know uh seller that
it was but you know he might have been
the idea that it wasn't going to sell at
all might have crossed his mind as well
right
so um
it's lit it's a little bit hard to
predict because it's you know it's not
true that all good writers don't make
money but it is true in a general kind
of way that writers cannot expect to
make money and you cannot you know music
we are doing the opposite of creating a
product you know so we you know you
think about you everything that you do
to create a successful product you know
where you have this idea you think that
it's what people want
and then you check to see if it's what
they really want right and then you try
to get it to be exactly what they want
so that they'll buy it and um if it's
you know
we hope that you would also you're a
corporation that you also think well is
this good for the world is it good for
the environment or so on
but let's face it the the process of of
product making is primarily about making
it what people want and if it turns out
that it's really bad for their health or
the environment or someone's like you
know that's like oh you know we find
ourselves in this position but that's
not their first concern right
ours is exactly the opposite you know
which is that you know it's like you
know i'm not we're not it's
it's you know we still want to make up
something that people will want to read
and we'll find engaged engaging and
provocative but you cannot imagine that
a gazillion people will all want to be
provoked that way you know you just
can't
um
like i say you know you you write it as
accessibly as you can um hopefully
you're writing about an america that
people recognize you know in my case you
know right right world town and you know
the place of fundamentalists and you
know immigrants and you know you can
sort of see um globalization all these
things going on hopefully people
recognize our world in that world and
that gives them you know it means that
they don't they say to their book group
you know should really
uh talk about this book because there's
so much to talk about
um but it's not fundamentally designed
to be exactly the book that you
wanted me to write right it's it's a
different book and because it was like i
say it is it's it's really almost an
anti-product it's not a product right
and um
and therefore you cannot expect to be
rewarded handsomely um that said you
know i mean i myself i've gotten a lot
of brands you know and you know i i mean
i do sell enough books you know so you
know you kind of have to kind of you
know you do sell i do sell enough books
and i like i say i'm very lucky um to
have had the kind of grand support that
i've had
um and um i you know it's funny i'd say
i've said to a friend this is also kind
of i feel like i am sort of personally
in a kind of patronage system you know
where or you know i don't have official
patrons you know but
you know um
but you know i i i'm too embarrassed to
give any particular examples but you
know if i want to go to a conference and
it's it's very expensive
and um i have a professional reason you
know related to my work i might want to
go to this conference
you know lo and behold
you know there's somebody who will say
you can go to this conference um
and there's so like i say there's a lot
of
kind of kind of just support of what i'm
doing because i'm doing it and i you
know i do receive this kind of support
um in in many different forms
and um
and so it's you know in in a weird kind
of way
there is kind of a modern version
of the patronage system as was what i
see that kind of augments the actual
dollars and cents which are the numbers
a little lower than you might like if
you have children going to college and
as we began john updike named you his
successor juno diaz has praised you your
books are
well reviewed well rewarded or well
awarded as well which one of your
novels guest jen is most often used as a
textbook in high school or college
you know i
i don't know
um but i think it may still be typical
american
and uh first book 1991 1991 you know so
so to give you an idea of you know so
what can happen for a literary writer
like me so you know like i say you know
so i've never been on the bestseller
list in nowhere near um on the other
hand
um you know usually when you sell a book
um
you know it's you sell it for 15 a 15
year period and the you know and the
assumption is that at the end of 15
years it's worth zero
right so you basically sell the rights
to them to publish it for 15 years
and then the rights revert to you and
because it's worth zero
well in the case of typical american
actually
i got to sell the book again
you know because this book was not
anywhere near dead in 15 years no i got
a second advice and a second advance for
that book
and so you know that's an example of
so you know not a bestseller but clearly
has been selling straight through since
1991
till today
um and so you know so i'm still seeing
royalties on that book so every once in
a while a check arrives and you're like
yeah no no no i said royalties every
year on typical american
so
so you know the fact that i actually
really said something you know a typical
american as you know is really um
questions the idea of what a typical
american is sort of it's not you know
it's asked the question it's in typical
america really somebody lives on a farm
eats apple pie or you know as soon as we
ask that question and what does it mean
to be jewish american chinese american
irene american
you know this book you know suggests
that at that point maybe you are an
american
so americans are defined by a
preoccupation with identity and you know
i think that that idea has actually um
proven to be a very important idea and
um so people are still teaching it but
in truth all the books are all the books
are so thought now if you can't get
through on the phone lines for novelist
gish jen you can contact us via social
media at book tv is our handle at
facebook instagram twitter
booktv seespan.org is our email
and jonathan and milwaukee you're on the
air
you know what i don't know what's wrong
with me today
jonathan in milwaukee i apologize
it's okay thank you very much for taking
my call and
i wanted to say i recently read a story
of yours that was published in the new
yorker or was excellent and i wanted to
ask
what's the process like
for
having a short story published in the
new yorker working with their editors
versus
writing a novel separately and working
with your novels publisher is the
methods differently do you have
different thoughts in mind for how to
craft the short story when it's
published in a magazine
versus having it be a novel that's going
to be sold in bookstores thank you very
much thank you that's an interesting
question um you know the answer is you
know you just you just write your story
or you write your book you know you
you're not that you're certainly not
thinking like what if the new yorker
takes it you know you just you just
write it and um and and and i have to
say that that's fully you know that
takes all of your brain cycles and
there's really not a lot left over um so
i'm mostly thinking you know does it
live does it work you know what is it
really about you know um you know you
know can i sharpen this character in
some way can i sharpen this bit of
dialogue in some way um i am very very
lucky in that i um of course the
editorial the new yorker is unbelievably
wonderful um and i'm very lucky also in
having a very very wonderful
editor at knuff i have had the same
editor ann close
since my second book so she's done both
my fiction and my non-fiction with the
exception of tiger writing which was on
harvard university press
and um
you know anne um is is she's an editor's
editor um and um and you know and i will
say that um but you know it's true that
um the new yorker just or at least my
experience they don't ask you
um
they don't maybe they don't see the
their job to help you write the thing
that you're writing you know um
working with anne um
and people think the editors kind of
like take things out you know you've
written too much in the second like get
rid of that ending change this character
um i don't get that at all i think that
i tend to be very hard on myself and so
you know if i send a draft to n and the
second draft i've taken all this stuff
out you know um
and will say something like and it was
apparently memorized the first draft
will say something like
i see that you have cut such and such an
image
i rather liked such and such an image
and i say oh okay and i'll put it back
in and then just say
and i see that you've cut such a line
i rather liked such and such a line and
i'll say okay i'll put it back in
this goes on for six hours
like i said during what she appears to
have noticed every single cut that i
made um she thinks that i can be too
high that i can cut too hard and that um
that you know like like i'll cut my own
toes off if i you know i kind of get
bored and it's gone um and so um
you know so in my relationship with the
new yorker and i haven't had that many
stories in new yorker um you know
someone like deborah traceman would
never say something like that to me i
can't imagine that you would say you
know i see you cut such such a line and
i rather like switches to the line um
it is very different um i will say the
the editing at the new yorker is
fantastic um
very very very careful about every word
every comma every everything
the one question that i did get on on
this last story no more maybe
she wondered why it had to be in pigeon
english you know which was an
interesting question because i had done
this earlier story was irish many years
ago
um
so it's not like i do use that voice all
the time it's only the second time since
1999 or something
um but you know of course since you know
since 1990 between 1999 and now um the
idea that people are actually writing
you know that people are speaking
another language and it's simply being
represented as english has become very
much better established than it was in
1999. that's because of writers like ian
lee for instance you know i mean we
understand that her characters are
chinese but of course they're just
speaking this english um but you know i
i um held firm with with the pigeon
english in this case and um you know i
wrote a little thing about it this
little q a thing that they do for the
new yorker um you know and that is
because i think honestly for me there's
something really poignant
about the pigeon english um i mean i i
myself um
have had the experience of trying to
explain something
in chinese so i know exactly what it's
like to be able
you know be trying to
convey to somebody somebody
someone else something that you know you
are you trying to convey something
across that language barrier
and i guess this is sort of say so i
look at it i don't just see it as broken
english
i see it as kind of this this beautiful
thing that people try to do
um and so i think it's a shame to kind
of to lose that so you know so i did
argue that that was an important part of
the story and that it added kind of this
you know the disappointments to that
voice and that um of course i could take
it out but i i really didn't want to
take it out um
and deborah treason did agree
um and uh but you know in a general kind
of way um you know they they are just
massively careful in every way shape or
form um and as a writer you can only be
grateful to be read that carefully i
will say um i just feel like it's just
it's an honor really to work with either
her or or and close um it is it is
different i guess like i s you know like
i say i mean i
um
maybe they just raise different things
because they're different people and
something like um the use of the pigeon
english i don't think at this point it
would even occur to my book editor to
question that um and that's why it's
nice to have a second editor you know
just sort of things that you know you
think are are a given it's nice to have
somebody ask you about them so that you
yourself have to think about them again
five novels your last two books have
been non-fiction
hmm
why is that
well um i would never have written any
non-fiction at all um had i not been
asked by um harvard the you know the
american studies department um if i
would give the massey lectures which is
big annual lectureship um everybody
comes it's a big it's big to do
um in truth i had when they first asked
me about it i'd say no um
well i was working well working on world
in town obviously honestly i was not
anxious to do this there's a lot of
pressure
i feel like i know these harvard
academics and like they are very tough
and um i know you know i just thought
anyway i was working on world in town
but um
no sooner did i finish my book i mean i
had hit send and like almost five
minutes later somebody hear that you've
you finished your novel
and of course i had just finished i mean
it's public information i can't hide it
so um so i did have to say yes um
and then well you know what's hard about
it is because of course you know to give
lectures like that you have to try to
think of something
that someone hasn't already said and so
much has been said i mean
these guys have done so much of the
saying of it you know
so you just feel like um you know i once
heard um after orahan pamela get his
norton lectures and i was behind a
professor and
and uh you know
somebody said the professor said
i know about 20 people who could have
given that lecture
i wish i had you know i wish i didn't
know these things you know i'm thinking
oh yeah yeah so the one thing that's
clear to me is that i have to say
something where no one is going to come
out and say i know about 20 people who
could get the lectures you know i was
like oh my god
um
and so you know the bar is pretty high
but as it turned out i did have
something to say and i was actually you
know in respect i was very glad
that i had had you know some little
provocation to get me to say
um what i had to say
um and that was that i as i was very
clear to me now that i was a writer who
kind of spanned
kind of an older world where
everything about
writing and the self
came out of you know what we call a mine
shaft
society right so a society that is based
in agriculture and communities um
a very you know kind of these intimate
you know village like life um it became
clear to me that that
whole culture
um
you know that it it influences not only
how you see yourself it means the kind
of selfies it certainly influences your
self expression influences your memory
it influences um your manners it
influences every single thing about you
and it certainly influences your fiction
and it's clear to me that i had made a
transition from that self
and that set of
you know that whole way of being like i
say which includes some very intimate
things
to this new self which is what you know
with the sociologists called the cell
shaft cell so meaning a self that is
based on a mobile modern industrialized
society
where the values are very different you
know so just things like how important
is your family of course we still think
our family is is important but it's not
so much the extended family you know
it's it's really a nuclear family just
you know you your you know your spouse
your kids and it's a much smaller family
and of course you know there's a much
cleaner boundary around the cell around
the individual so because why is that
well because it's you know it's a
capitalist world where it was you know
what's the ideal work the ideal worker
in this world is somebody with no ties
right i mean the ideal worker can walk
24 7 and you tell them to relocate and
they go but that's the ideal capitalist
worker
the ideal agricultural worker is
somebody who has a lot of ties so that
you know what i mean it's time to put up
that farm you're going to be able to put
that barn up yourself you know somebody
who knows that the whole village will
come and help and who has themselves
gone and put up many of barn themselves
i mean it's a completely different way
of being in the world with like i say
with meaning different
so many differences and certainly many
differences that pertain to writing and
so that's how i wrote this book title
writing art culture and the
interdependent self to really describe
my own journey they had wanted me to
write an intellectual autobiography
and this is a big hugely salient thing
about me that i had made this journey
and that um and that it was all over
all of my books
um and so i wrote about that
so why did i not just stop once i wrote
and then i'd go say that that was the
moment which i realized not only how
much i had made by my own books how much
writing had made me and helped me
develop this other self
but um it also you know it's great to
have the words for myself and i will say
some of the um the very most germane
research it just so happens was very
happily just coming out because all the
um the research about the self
and narrative was just coming out as i
was writing my lectures is done by chi
wong and cornell university and so those
i mean the papers are being published
almost as i was writing so it was very
very exciting and i was so grateful to
have it because it explained so many
things that were kind of
weird or unconventional about my work
and um the way that i saw things i could
see was a little bit different than most
of my um
colleagues and it explained so much
and then when i was done with them so
did you know i was kind of what do i do
now
and i suddenly realized that i went to
china i realized like oh i see they're
all these people
expats who lived lived in china for 25
years
and the chinese were still a complete
mystery to them you know and they just
didn't you know they could see it was
just everything and they couldn't they
didn't know why
and then of course in this country i saw
all these all these people with with
with you know colleagues in asia and
other places you know these students in
china in american classrooms
the teachers just don't know what to do
you know the teachers would do things
like they're trying to get people to
relax the first day of class and they
would say things well write an essay
about yourself only to have all the
chinese students freeze
and far from being put at their ease you
know there's a creative writing class
where you know where the student was
asked you know to write this essay about
herself and she left you know what i
mean the professor was like what is
going on and i felt like i was saying oh
i see actually i just wrote this book it
was really about me and literary culture
but actually i actually understand
something now that will be vastly
helpful to all of these people
and people who are not going to pick up
a psychology book that a study study
study study you know i mean they you
know i knew how to say it in a way too
that i could explain it to them so i
wrote this book that was the girl of the
baggage claim
and um
and now you're going to ask what i'm
going to do next but we'll talk about
that first before you ask it so what now
oh my god she's just taking this big
detour but go ahead well we'll come back
to this but we want to show a little
video of you talking about both
tiger writing
and the girl at the baggage claim okay
[Music]
well you know i am a novelist but there
was something that i knew in my bones
that i had just somehow never quite
managed to get out onto the page despite
30 years of writing this feeling that
the writing world had certain
assumptions about where
you know where the truth was that the
writing world valued certain things that
were very different than the things that
i had valued growing up
and that it narrated in a way that was
very different
than the way we narrated
in my childhood home i was not a
narrative native you know we didn't do
this in my family you know i was not
asked um you know what do you want is it
what i wanted was a very important thing
what do i like you know you know
you know i was not encouraged to think
of myself as a unique individual whose
uniqueness was really a very important
thing um quite the contrary and so
therefore it wasn't really until i
started reading that i realized that in
the west in this world that we had found
ourselves that this was a very
foundational idea that it started with
pictures of you as a baby like i don't
have any pictures of myself
you know one minute after i was born you
know
um
and in fact i have very few pictures of
myself and there are very few stories
also about me as a child as i start to
get interested in this whole question of
of narrative difference you know which
is tied to a difference in self and a
difference in perception
i happened to
start to work on my father's
autobiography
that's something that he had written
when he was 85
and
i have to say when i had first looked at
it it just made no sense at all to me i
mean here was this thing that was
supposed to be an autobiography
about his
growing up in china um and yet
he himself did not appear
until page eight you know you know so
you know this this autobiography did not
start you know i was born you know i was
born in in this such and such a year no
no no no it started you know way way way
before that thousands years before that
went through the generations um i think
that also by the time my father gets to
his birth
i mean he mentions his birth date in
parenthesis
in conjunction with with an with an
another event
and i remember reading that and thinking
well how very interesting um i think
that i could both see that it was quote
unquote weird from a western narrative
point of view and yet of course there
was something about it which was
incredibly familiar to me and i
understood this i understood this
diminishment of the self i mean it was
you know it was you know what i mean one
thing was something i knew with my left
hand and one thing was something i knew
was my right because i had this conflict
you know between an interdependent self
and an independent self and both of
which are in me
um
i did have an artistic preoccupation and
something which i had to say you know
what you would have to say was was
definitely mine
and so there is a way in which um even
as i inhabit all these other people in
all my fiction regardless of what i'm
talking about
i am also still there so there's a way
in which um
this problem if you will that i have the
split between independence and
independence has been a tremendous thing
for me as a fiction writer
gish what's the genesis of your book and
what do avocado pits have to do with it
well you know um
like lenora very interested in education
and um you know i heard a story
a couple of years ago um this story
involved milton academy which some of
you may know it's very prestigious new
england prep school
and what happened was that a girl had
applied to milton
she had great um toefl scores she had
great essays um they did a skype
interview with her she did a great
interview and um
they admitted her they're very excited
and then you know as they went to pick
her up from the airport and right away
they realized that something was a
little bit off
and um you know as the semester went on
it became clear that the girl had come
was not the girl who had done the skype
interview but her sister
and you know i was told this story by um
ahead of an of another independent
school that was since corroborated by
milton
and you know they just told the story
just like you know all the heads of
schools are talking about it just like
it this is just so strange
but when i heard that story i thought
this is not so strange actually i this
is in asia this business is substituting
one person for another uh this very kind
of close teamwork um is actually very
common and um so i recognize this
pattern and but as i talked more to the
educators i could see that there were
many things about this new cohort of
chinese students that were just
completely baffling
to
to the educators here um and also you
know i spent a lot of time in china i
could see that in china the reverse was
also true you know i was teaching at um
nyu shanghai where their whole mission
is to bring u.s education to china and i
could see there's just a way in which
there are a lot of things about their
chinese students that you know i mean
that they didn't get and that the
chinese students the china didn't get
about the school
and i just thought you know what i
actually understand both sides of this
and um there is a book where i can
explain it you know because there's a
lot of deep research right and avocado
and avocados well and what i was what i
realized that the piece of information
that they were missing
was that the cell that dominates in the
east and the southwest dominance in the
west are very different you know the in
the west we have a self that is like an
avocado we imagine that we have a big
pit in the center of us a sacred pit i
will say you know this is the thing that
we call ourself we feel that this is our
identity you know the whole purpose of
u.s education is to understand the
nature of this identity to identify its
strengths and weaknesses develop it to
develop its voice and then we're very
we're very much committed to making sure
that it is free expression that it can
move freely and this is the model that
we have um but actually research has has
established that you know in the rest of
the world and i do mean like most of the
rest of the world meaning asia africa
south america central and eastern europe
a lot of places in western europe a lot
of places in the united states and even
in the united states itself until fairly
recently
a different self
actually dominates and that's a self
that's much more like a you know like a
um like a gumby
and it's it's a fl it's a flexi cell a
self that it that is just as full of
agency as the as the avocado itself i
mean it is fully capable of traveling
abroad or you know what i mean opening
restaurants doing all these things that
we think of you know it it's not that
it's um i think when we use that
collectivistic we imagine that that
somehow this is a self that only you
know they can't take any initiative and
that's completely wrong you know i mean
anybody goes to asia you know there's
plenty of initiative there's plenty of
entrepreneurship
but what's different is
the meaning of it in other words where
where is it coming from so when they
sort of say oh my god like everything
they don't care about branding or when
it comes to law firms you know and you
know here you have
you know sydney austin there's a sibley
and there's an austin you know in china
you know you have you have you have a
law firm it's thompson rose
there's no thompson and there's no roads
you know because that whole idea you
know the idea is you know our law firms
you know there's an idea there's kind of
an integrity involved there are actual
people there and so the law firms you
know are kind of our emanations of these
people and their avocado pits
you know whereas the chinese law firms
they don't have this idea at all you
know like what do you think is a good
name oh you think they'll like thompson
rose okay let's use that
it's a it's a completely different view
so you can sort of see it's much more
geared to what will work you know oh
that'll work we'll do that
it's my first day teaching in shanghai a
few of my students are from china but
most are lucky undergraduates from nyu
abu dhabi whose entire education
including such study abroad is gratis
an arab royal interested in bringing
world-class education to the emirates is
funding them and so it is that they have
come all from all over the world some
are freshmen some are seniors it's a
motivated gifted class and yet for all
of that a few
only a few are comfortable
talking
in class
you were talking just right there about
the difference yeah
what chinese students
what american teachers of chinese
students are facing yeah well as i said
in the tape you know it isn't only
actually the chinese students you know i
think that we're most aware of them
because they look different right so we
can still see this a whole group of
people who look different and who are
uncomfortable speaking in class um but
actually it's many many many more people
and the number of people have come up to
me from you know romania or
lithuania other places have said and
said oh my god that's me
um but i don't have the you know i don't
have the difference um you know the
physical difference but
that's me too and that's you know and
that is the way that we are in our
culture and that it is so uncomfortable
to talk in class and you know now we
have the studies that sort of say when
they say they're uncomfortable they're
not just shy their cortisol levels are
spiking the roof i mean it's you know
they're having a physiological
response to having to do this thing
which is so against everything that
they've been taught
and um you know what you know of course
the question the educators always want
to know is well so are we kind of is
this you know western hegemony to make
them speak this way and you know of
course it is
you know but um the question is then
well then do we not make them speak in
class and well do i make them please
speak in class like answers i do i do um
i do because i view it as being very
much like speaking english
in one way of course it is a reflection
of western dominance in the world that
they are everyone has to speak english
on the other that
that is the state of affairs and it will
open all kinds of doors for them i said
you know so if you do not regret having
learned english
you will not regret learning to speak up
in class
and the same way that english is
uncomfortable and hard to learn and it
is hard for you to learn to speak up in
class
you can do it i know it because i did it
you know i i did it so i know exactly
hard for you extremely hard
so i mean it's just so funny today i
mean you look at me what are your my
what are your p what were your parents
telling you that made it so hard well
they don't it's not anything that the
parents say
right i mean they don't tell you don't
speak up in class they don't say that
but it is you know this this is the self
that we're talking about the word that
doesn't speak up in class you know that
is laid down by things like how closely
you're held you know as a baby you know
and what you're in the kind of in the
kind of way that your mother talks to
you you know so that um so things like
you know it's funny like i myself you
know i'm growing up as you can see you
know very assimilated speaks english
blah blah blah you know i myself did not
really realize that i had kind of other
self until um i had a child myself
and uh we were going around the new
mother's group the kids are like six
weeks old right they're very little and
we're going around a circle
and um everyone is sort of asking what
do you want your baby to be
and everyone else says they want their
child to be independent i'm like
independent they can't help their heads
i want my job to be happy you know and
and also very strikingly everybody else
had taken their baby and just put the
baby on the floor now they were on
receiving blankets but this is a
hardwood floor they put the kid's elbow
i could not put my child i mean i
physically could not put
i could not put him down
and
and i you know it's just striking and
the question is like how did i even
learn that i mean i you know grew up in
new york and
how how did i know that that in chinese
culture you don't put those kids down
you know they you know really many many
cultures any interdependent cultures the
kid just goes from one person holding
them to the next no one puts that child
it's not done on the floor
um the child is never without physical
contact with somebody
and where did i learn that it's so
interesting about culture because you
know i'm growing up and you know queens
and then youngers and scores down new
york and i guess you know i did have
little brothers um you know when i was
quite old because my youngest brother is
probably eight years younger than me um
so i did see them when they're infants
but the answer is you know these are
very
deeply embedded things you know so it's
a lot of this is embedded before way way
way before you can talk
and then of course
how do they talk to you and this is
where chi wang and cornell has done such
interesting work you know i'm not just
too long others too i will say this is
many many people have worked on this
and you know so are they is the child's
um attention directed to objects
or is it related to who is that oh that
is your uncle that is your uncle and
you're you know on your father's side
you know in other words how do you talk
to them and when you talk to them and
you ask them so what did you think about
this you know what you know what is your
opinion or what you know what happened
to you what is the story to you
why did you do that was that what you
were supposed to do right is that was
just you know uh weren't you supposed to
get your homework in why didn't you get
your homework in you know
not you know so not what you everything
that you desire you know what do you
want to be when you grow up but kind of
like well why didn't you do that you
know so it's very different so the
emphasis on there was something that
that you were supposed to do meaning you
had a role and kind of did you fulfill
that role or not
is really the emphasis
as opposed to kind of you know do you
have the self and what is the nature of
that self and very importantly what is
unique about that self um nobody cares
in chinese culture you know kind of how
unique you are you know
you know the answer is of course it's
kind of they have the long view which is
like you know however you know you may
think you're unique but you know if you
look over 2000 years of chinese history
you know you're not that unique you know
it's a very different perspective but
anyway these things get you know and
then it's kind of and then when when do
you speak up and certainly um it
speaking up with like
i have something to say
is extremely uncomfortable
and so they don't speak up and i have to
say that you know even people who are
you know you know there are people who
have this in them who can be kind of
very very very you know well integrated
into it in the western world so an
example with salman rushdie you know you
think certainly he is not going to have
expression you know trouble talking
about himself i mean
but you know when he sat down to write
his his memoir about his years under the
fatwa you know that was after the ayatok
tolokamini had
you know had issued this fatwa you know
what a death sentence on him because
of his heretical writings um
and the satanic verses um
when it came time to write his his
memoir he found that he could not write
in the first person
he could not say i i i i
and he wrote that whole memoir as he in
the third person you know and um when
you look at that when you sort of see
it's like oh so even somebody like many
many many many years into
you know
you know life in the western world
this residual feeling of like it's not
okay to say i uh to be focused on
yourself like that um it you know stays
with you stays with you and i'm to this
day i mean i you know interviewed just
about myself
i can go a little you know i'm very
happy to talk about you know the
classroom and america and fundamentalism
and talking about myself you know i mean
i can get there but i i have to kind of
there's like a little speed bump i think
kind of an over the speed bump and so i
understand these students you know it's
kind of like i too if you had asked me
you know when i was
in 11th grade say to write about myself
i also would have frozen you know and
then teachers will say things like and
tell me what's unique about yourself
which is exactly the wrong question and
the teacher said to me so you know i
asked my students you know what was
unique about them and they would say
things like well i have a little brother
and teacher's reaction that's not so
unique you know but but um but that's
you know in other words the students
were clearly jamming on on that question
i'm like you know don't don't don't ask
them that you know and not if you're
trying to get them to relax i mean
definitely don't ask them that but but i
understand that because i myself um
would have been very very very
uncomfortable with that question and
it's not a language thing look i was
born in the united states
culture is very persistent and um like i
said because it's laid down um so so
early and i would say even really not in
the second generation into the third
generation i can definitely see my
children well i want to ask that can you
see a difference between your parents
and your kids oh of course it's not that
it also it's not that culture doesn't
change you know what i mean i mean it's
not that it doesn't it does not that
culture doesn't change it's not that
there's you know that there's a change
between the generations obviously
because like i developed this big
other self as a result of my reading and
you know living in america
um
like i said but it's it's a hybrid self
and what i see of course my children
um you know different than me different
very different than my parents
but the surprise is how much continuity
there is too you know i mean it you know
it it it is surprising obviously
very happy to talk about themselves and
you know
and um
you know
but you would also have to say you know
there's a way in which you know
everybody wants to know what did you do
like i don't want to boast on air but my
kids came out great you know
you know in the sense that they have a
sense of um belonging to a family is a
kind of obligation to the family um
there's an intimacy there a closeness
there that um those are the good parts
from the old world
um
there's you know
there are a lot of very special
qualities there also and they've
retained those so you know so
um
and to a remarkable degree different
than their classmates you know so an
example would be um
my daughter was moving out of her dorm
room um her dorm room and um they had
bought a couch and you know the other
one was all left and they did move their
their
their couch out you know i mean you
can't leave this couch here for you know
the custodians to to you know to take
care of i mean like you know when you
brought that catching it's your
responsibility they catch out and she of
course including me you know so she and
my son took it out you know but the in
that in those little ways you could sort
of see that actually
she saw herself you know as part of a
whole
you know you're it's you to which you
have a responsibility
um and this is the way that you behave
in this whole no one is no one is
watching no one's gonna come and yell at
you because you left the scout here
you just don't do that you know period
you just don't do that and you know kind
of you know that's just a little example
but all the way down the line i think
that i can see that my children have
this idea that actually we belong to a
larger world and
and um yeah they're you know
you know you're not like a marble kind
of you know a little rolled onto
yourself you
you've launched a larger world to which
you have obligations
michael fayette alabama you are on the
air with gishjin on book tv please go
ahead with your question
good afternoon it's a real honor to um
be able to
speak with you ask you these questions i
have two
i'm an aspiring writer i'm trying to get
as much practice in as my full-time uh
commercial art and studio art business
will allow but that does have something
to do with it um
with my question
i don't know whether to ask you both
questions and then hang up michael if
you would just go ahead state your
questions
and then we'll get an answer okay
well the first one is
do you have any advice for
people
interested in children's book writing
um
especially for people who come at it
from a
practice and or a career of being a
cartoonist an animator or a picture
illustrator because i draw in the mgm
warner brothers disney style
and i know to start out
okay michael that's the first question i
apologize we have other callers on hold
what's your second question is oh i hate
these
kickrazer go kick me
funstarter.com and so forth
and i believe it's possible for me to
get into the publishing at least in a
small way like comic books for instance
without
using those for any uh startup capital
but if the day comes i hate the way that
they're these fights that were started
for
visual artists and people in
non-performing arts and the performing
arts i guess uh were uh are now being
abused for as animation magazine once
said five years ago
michael i apologize i'm going to have to
leave it we've got the questions
aspiring
writers
children genres
and
the gofundme how how to get started yeah
when it comes to i have to say that i
have no expertise whatsoever when it
comes to children literature so i'm so
sorry i wish i could help you i love
children's literature and i'm happy to
see more people um write for it and and
i will say that it seems to me that
someone who has a background and graphic
anything is at a tremendous advantage um
because i do think we see more and more
of this this wonderful cartooning thing
going on and um i mean i'm sure this is
it's really really really a great thing
to have um that's it i'm sorry to say
that i know nothing about it and um and
um on the you know on the gofundme front
um i actually don't know that i actually
don't think that writers um need to have
any capital raised you you know you need
to have money to cover your time so you
need to be able to take time off from
your work um you're paying work in order
to write um
what it looks like it's just not a
lucrative activity in and of itself um
but actually i don't think that you do
need to have like an indiegogo campaign
or anything like that to write your book
um you know all you need is time an idea
some some images
and and a story line and i wish you all
the luck in the world half hour left
with our guest here on our special
fiction edition of in-depth guest jen
202 is the area code 748 8200 if you
live in the east and central time zones
202-748-8201 for those of you in the
mountain and pacific time zones george
in fort myers florida good afternoon
hi
i uh
i read your essay on catcher in the rye
and
and i'm wondering if you don't see
huckleberry finn
as a successful person like holden he's
he's unique and he's interesting and
he's entertaining and he's telling his
own story and he's a kid but he's a
successful person but holden is
attractive because he's a failure as a
person you see do you think that too
well you know i think that um i think
finn is a wonderful character so funny i
don't really think about whether they're
a success or a failure as people it's
kind of an interesting question um
you know holden is you know his his
claim to fame is not whether he's
successful or or unsuccessful um so much
as he's somebody who doesn't accept the
artifice of his world and of course
neither is huck finn
and so
you know i think you're um
i you know i in a general kind of way to
um to rail against the the artifice of
your society is not generally a a recipe
for success um i think it's a recipe for
personal fulfillment so it is it's a
path towards maybe
a more authentic life um but it isn't
necessarily
a
path toward a more successful life i
mean those things can go hand in hand um
i mean it does they go hand in hand for
instance for writers but for many other
people um they can be quiet at odds so i
don't know if that answers your
questions but um
but for what it's worth i i think that
as characters um i think that both huck
finn and and holden caulfield are just
unbelievably successful characters and
i'm so glad that their authors invented
them about 45 million copies of catcher
in the writing yeah well of course of
course although interesting well well
because you know what what makes that a
good book
well you know you know interesting i did
write this thing you know in many ways
from um the point of view of um from a
writing point of view it's a mess
you know so like you know you know
there's really there's no sign that you
know that that salinger you know ever
read the art of fiction you know by
henry james you know i mean this you
know it's a mess
um
but
clearly
you know he's he's on something i mean
partly with the times you know was this
the 50s youthquake that was going on you
know so you know i think it's easy from
our perspective to remember just how we
press the 50s was and kind of you know
kind of overly scripted you know that
babbitt world you know and all of a
sudden you know we get hold and
caulfield who basically says you're all
a bunch of ponies right
and um you know that word phony i mean
that you know he's very early to sort of
say you guys
you know you're so inauthentic you know
like how can you live with yourself you
know and i and i think that that you
know that hit a very big chord obviously
and i think of course especially on the
young
um who are just in the middle of trying
to figure out who they are and and also
becoming aware that society has all
these ideas about how they should live
their lives you know and the 60s and of
course it was this huge explosion right
um a huge explosion although one again
you know it was not seen by the
publisher i think it was turned by like
down by like 13 houses or something
can you imagine scheduling the ride
turned around by 13 houses but in any
case um so you know i think that you
know this so this this idea that you
know to thine own self be true but kind
of in its you know 60s incarnation you
know it was embodied in in um holden
caulfield
and um
and uh yeah no i mean i'm not surprised
that it it it sold so many copies i
think what's so surprising to us today
is that many young people
do not relate to holden anymore and i
think that those of us who grew up in
the you know the 60s 70s were like
you're kidding now where's your
rebelliousness you know but the number
you know i um i talked about this i was
teaching at brandeis for a while i
remember talking about this with my
class and
you know most of the students just felt
that he was like kind of really immature
and like what was his problem you know
somebody you know to us he was you know
he was our he was the anti-hero to end
all anti-heroes and um and uh we
respected his you know his his bravery
and his honesty
and um and you know it's it was very
interesting to me just you know to see
that the you know this younger
generation um didn't didn't see him that
way and but i mean i think what we're
seeing with the younger younger
generation i'm talking about like the
parkland um
protesters and so on i think it's it's
interesting they are also rebellious but
they're but they're it's it's much more
they're rebellious in a socially
responsible way right so you know they
want to see the gun laws changed you
know so it's not it's not this romantic
like goal it's just i want to be free to
be me
that's not what they're saying you know
that's i mean that was that was kind of
the the tune of an earlier generation i
want to be me you know that's not what
they're saying you know i think they're
just saying i don't want to be shot you
know it's really what they're saying um
but it is it is interesting to see um to
see you know the movement uh towards
something which is a little less a
little less self-focused and a little
more socially focused
2013
you got yourself in a bit of trouble
with a
boston globe essay
oh god
that's true um what happened was that
you know um on the heels of of the of
the boston red sox winning the world
series um the boston globe asked a
number of people in boston from are you
a fan of the red sox of course
i mean it goes without saying
but anyway they asked us to write a um
a piece about um what this victory meant
in light of um
you know the marathon bombings the the
year before
and you know to me it was you know it
was very um very striking that you know
some of the big stars you know were
immigrants you know big papi and um
the picture whose name has just gone out
of my head right now but you know but
who had to give his post-game interview
in japanese with the translator yeah
yeah thank you um and um you know and um
so
it was a very big moment to see these
two immigrants
so prominent
in this victory um and i had so you know
and the kind of the warmth of the of the
of the you know the boston um
fan base for them and i just i had to
say well you know this is a big moment
for boston boston very not well known
for its problems with bossing and so on
it's xenophobia um we seem to have
reached a different place and since the
assignment was
about you know about the boston
marathons and i say in very marked
contrast
to the you know to jahar and his brother
the tsarnaevs um you know and and it
just i just asked the question
you know did we really did we do right
by the surmise that's the only really
ass now i have to say that was really
first of all i had i had more than 400
words i probably would have filled that
out a little more
um
and um and it was i was a very natural
question to ask for me especially since
i'm dzhokhar tsarnaev he's the younger
brother um
you know had actually gone to high
school with my daughter so he they'd
gone to the same high school so you know
i knew i didn't know him personally but
you know i knew his math teacher he had
tutored people in math he was on the
wrestling team he was actually a very
popular guy he had gone to all the
parties so it was kind of a natural
question as a concern
yeah was a concern yeah and a concerned
cambridge parent to sort of say you know
did
is it was something we could have done
did we let them down you know in some
way
and um
like i said i still stand by that
question i mean how could this kid have
been
right there how could nobody have seen
that this could something like this was
in the offing or even the remotest
possibility how could we not have seen
it
and um
and anyway before that i got completely
you know drawn and quartered by i will
say a certain part of
the boston population
this is very much fanned by the
right-wing
um
sports um sportscasters
and you know and i guess what i see now
which i did not understand now but these
are the guys who are going to go on to
vote for trump so it's that same
section so this is the same part of the
population that it's so opposed busing
um they were still there um and like i
say we do have this right wing
right-wing
sportscasters who really fan that up um
and because of this one question did we
do right by the surnames you know was
there something else we could done which
is really to me
not
an inflammatory question
um you know they had that they launched
this campaign they threatened my agent
in new york um i came to a best american
short stories uh reading which i was
supposed to read and there were three
police cruisers out front with the
sirens going like what's going on and i
was like oh my god they're here to
protect me i mean
you know because there were threats to
the library you had to be brought into
the back i mean it was crazy you know i
mean um they had this whole online
campaigns these all these pictures of me
it's like you know this is the portrait
of a white hater i'm like white hater
i'm married to it
what are you doing i mean it's just
crazy um
but like i said i think that it was my
you know so later on when we saw that
certain districts actually had voted for
trump i was not you know within
massachusetts i was not all together
surprised but you know i really did not
know these guys were there um and i
didn't understand also on how much yeah
they hated you know they hated the
immigrants still they're still very
upset about busing
um
and you even think and also the town
gown thing you know they live in
cambridge massachusetts you know how
much they hated the whole you know the
whole um crowd that that chopped at even
trader joe's and not even whole foods
the trader joe's because they all
stopped at market basket and um they
just thought that you know they just
they slammed me like she probably she
probably shops at trader joe's and you
know guilty as charged
but honestly you know even though i i
you know i keep a close eye on what's
going on in america i really had no idea
that this was such a virulent boundary
between people who dropped shop at
trader joe's and people who shop at
market basket and i did not know that
that you know they could say that and
that would be you know you're instantly
you know obviously one of one of them
and i like i say i had no idea that
boundary was so virulent
gishgen your last two books have been
non-fiction are you returning to fiction
um yes i am i will say um you know there
was a there was a moment in which i was
thinking well maybe i could write
another it was kind of fun you know i
was having a good time um but anyway
just as i was hanging in the balance
trying to figure out what to do um i
realized that i had um i had agreed um
to contribute to something to an
anthology that was being put together um
to benefit the aclu and so all of a
sudden i'm like oh my god you know i
haven't written any fiction since um
world in town and i've agreed to write
the story i kind of dragged my feet and
something was like it was due like in a
week you know kind of like two weeks
there's only 10 days like oh my god you
know i said you know sat down i wrote
and then bang out came the story that no
more maybe the story was in the new
yorker recently um and and then right
after another one two of them like
within you know i mean really within
days
um and i suddenly said oh i guess i
still are you still using the index
cards no i didn't even i was so i was so
kind of um
i was in so much trouble with this with
this um
that i didn't even try to look at chords
i just thought i sat down
i started typing and i and i popped out
these two stories
and then at that point i think i i and
also i love doing it more importantly
and i just realized like oh i see
actually i still love fiction i mean i
liked doing those books and i'm glad
very glad i wrote them
um
and i could see you know a lot of people
have said to me you know what i mean
they changed their lives and you know
david henry huang you know the
playwright of uh and butterfly said you
know this is the book explain me to
myself you know in other words it really
helped a lot of people that book and i'm
so i'm so happy to have done it and i
you know it's interesting for me and an
adventurer as well um but that's that i
can i can also see that the fiction
writing part of me is not over by any
means so i wrote those two stories and
then i am in the new novel in world in
town is there a character who is simply
a character and not maybe
representing something or
symbolic of something else
and i'm thinking ginny i'm thinking
hattie i'm thinking carter the
representative of the wasps well i don't
think i don't like that word
representative okay you know i mean
because i didn't think about it symbolic
of or definitely not symbolic of because
it's like they're you know you know
they're just people that you would find
in the community
i mean in other words
they're not you know and then it's not
just janine there's a lot of you know
other people who are also from that
world do you mean i mean you're you know
i mean it's so it's it's not you know
it's not like um
yeah i don't think of them as
representative and that every then their
people are not representative um just
any more than you know like i'm talking
to you but you're not representing the
white race and i'm you know what i'm
saying it's just like you know this is
two people but it is true that if you
look at a certain lens you could sort of
say oh i see here's this white host
intro you know what i mean
i don't know maybe that's sort of true
but it's sort of not true at the same
time so um i don't think about it that
way and when i was thinking about it um
because there's a way in which like i
say hattie is half wasp right so she's
not really not a wasp i mean she's you
know she has that
she's a confucius part she's got yeah
she is still the daughter of
missionaries without giving the book
away
what's the meaning of the parent's grave
in iowa
as a reader help me
help me
um
you know
i'll just sort of say so hattie's
hattie's parents um i was trying to do
this without giving the book away um so
hattie's parents
because her mother
was a missionary from iowa
they had
because of her father she had
the right the father had the right
to be married to be buried in the
confucian family graveyard
in chufu china which is a big deal it's
a very big deal can you ready to descend
into confucius it's like it's like a big
deal
and um
and uh so but because of
everything that's happened um they are
actually buried
um near hattie's mother's grave
um and um that in near paris which is in
iowa
and um you know that would be fine
except that um all of hattie's relatives
feel that they her chinese relatives
feel that they're having very bad luck
because her parents are buried in the
wrong place
and they really things are really not
going at all so they want the parents
relocated to china
and hattie who you know who is a science
teacher um is opposed to this because
she feels that it's you know it's this
ignorant superstition and she's just
against it you know
and um i will say that there's a little
bit you know the this the story has a
you know has some roots in a story my
own background
um and that is that um
my father
my my father's
mother
um was buried in taiwan and she was
buried there because of you know
political things so she was not buried
with my grandfather so my grandfather
was buried in their hometown which is
near outside of shanghai
and um and and
the but the family who's the family
responsible for my grandmother being in
taiwan wanted to move her to another
place that they had they thought had bet
it was better like a better feng shui it
was a better luck place within taiwan
and my father was very against this well
first of all they dug my grandmother up
without telling my father
and um
and then when she was dug up
he felt that if she was reburied she
should be
you know reburied with my grandfather um
and on the mainland on the mainland in
the special place that he had been
buried now he had been buried this is
kind of a long i don't know his arm
starts too long anyway he had been
buried in a special place that was now
actually a farm and so there was like a
new family graveyard in
nearby but not the original graveyard
and they wanted to put him there
um put actually both grandparents there
and my father definitely didn't want my
grandfather who was already happily in
the ground to be dug up or it's bad
enough they'd already
dig up my grandmother so he wanted my
grandmother to be my grandfather in this
special place it was now a farm that but
was still undisturbed which is also like
a special site it's hard to explain with
the feng shui there's like the best feng
shui
in china it's a fantastic place
and so
this aunt was on her way to go bury the
ashes in this new place that my father
opposed and i was supposed i was sent to
china to go stop her
you can't make the step up you know
i mean long story short i did manage to
stop her with my broken chinese and i
did manage to get my grandmother buried
in the place where my father wanted her
with my grandfather in this original
wonderful spot
and so i don't know if all's well that's
end well and i don't know whether
everybody's luck has settled down or not
um but i do i do know that that was
probably maybe the most important thing
that i've ever done for my father i mean
i i just know that this was the single
thing that he wanted like more than
anything else in the world was to see
his parents buried together in this
special original spot where she felt was
their spot
so behind us so you know i'm bringing to
this this other story in my book you
know i can understand how upset that
relatives are
about something that you know hattie you
know who's sort of you know south
america and just sort of feels like she
just doesn't get you know um it is true
that the iowa place is getting is near
of shopping center it's really kind of
unpleasant so you know you can see that
that's very big feng shui because now
it's there's a shot you know it's really
becoming terrible and she can see how
upset
um the the you know upset the um the
relatives are
and i don't mean to give voices but but
she and she does finally
finally
just say okay
and i think that she herself is a little
surprised at how much peace this gives
her
you know
and i guess you know i don't mean to say
well and this means that
she doesn't believe
in the things that they believe it's not
her belief system
but she can see in some kind of very
profound way
the tremendous
um
yeah the tremendous peace
and wholeness
that it gives her relatives and she is
happy to give that back to them
does that make sense
let's hear from rachel in tucson hi
rachel
good afternoon thank you for taking my
call
i'm enjoying the program but i was just
curious um
how does she know that the people who
castigated her
for
the column newspaper column
how about the boston bombers how did she
know they were
trump voters
thank you ma'am
you know that's a good question i
actually don't know that they voted for
trump but let me just say that i would
not be surprised because
i could see that they were very very
very very very very anti-immigrant
and i'm i can see that they were very
very very very anti-elite
you know so i think that you know i i
you know and i'm sure that just reflects
you know the
the obliviousness of the coastal elites
but you know
i i like to think that if i had met them
in a coffee shop that i would see them
as human beings a bit the way that
hattie kong is able to accept that her
relatives are
very different than her
but they that they find a kind of peace
and wholeness in something that she did
herself doesn't get at all but that she
just accepts them for what they are um i
would like to feel that if i met these
guys in a coffee shop that i would be
the same way that i would say okay you
know you you know you have a whole way
of different being and i accept that and
i would like to think that you know if
they met me that they would they would
accept that too you know um
but i have to say that you know this
incident um
told me that you know where they didn't
ever get to meet me um and they only got
to ver meet this very
uh distorted picture of me that had been
presented by these sportscasters
that
that i could see that there was a
virulence of reaction there
that um that i didn't get you know and
then you know i am a student of humanity
but it was just the
you know the readiness with which they
were willing to paint me like i say in
colors that i did not recognize at all
um
i you know i associate that with the
trump voters but of course i don't
really know how they voted and um you
know i mean i do know that there were
sections in massachusetts i mean we
think of messages as a liberal but the
fact of the matter is that it's not all
that liberal if you look at if you look
at the electric map actually there are
places that are very bright red
and um
i see you know overshadowed you know by
the urban areas and um so you're right i
don't actually know that but um but
there does seem to me to be kind of some
correlation between
the real massachusetts map which i could
say is much more complicated than we'd
like to think
and um and the behavior of of these um
of these fans that
that seem to me to be correlated
day one teaching
college students in their freshman year
what do you want them to know what do
you make them do
[Laughter]
well you know more than anything of
course you just want them to be
comfortable in the classroom
so they want you want them both to know
that they're going to be asked to do
things that maybe they don't want to do
or don't know how to do
and and then you want to be
them to be open to it so it is true that
for instance with this in this nyu class
in shanghai um you know i did put it
right on our very first assignment was
to look at this study i knew that a lot
of them would be uncomfortable talking
in class
very first thing is we looked at the
study and i asked them to look at the
study about people's cortisol levels
spiking when they were asked to do this
thing in the class i told them that they
were going to be asked to do it to do
this in class but i also asked them what
they thought about that you know so they
should write a little op-ed kind of like
well do you think that you know i am
right as a teacher to ask them to do
this thing that's gonna
cause them this uncomfortable
physiological reaction or not so i gave
them a voice you know i mean that was
not to say that i was not giving them a
choice because
because
my point was that by by signing up
to a class in nyu shanghai that they
knew that this is a western program
that's the whole point of this
university and um if they had not wanted
that then they should have gone to
you know a a you know the futon or any
one of the other chinese universities in
which case they would have been able
they would not have been challenged that
way and so if but by putting themselves
in this class they had if in effect
agreed to be challenged this way um but
i did give them a voice so that they
could prom you know it wasn't just like
and you will do it
so they could process themselves what
they thought of that and what they you
know ironically of course have an
opinion about it
and and what i did the second class uh
was i asked them to tell me what they
had written in their pieces about
whether they should have to talk in
class and yes they were going to have to
say it aloud in class
but where it was a subject where on
which they had such strong opinions um
that i did find that everybody kind of
opened up right there
like you know even i say no i should not
have to be taught me to talk in class
they said it
passionately and articulately in class
so
it worked like a charm jamie's in
beaumont texas jamie you're on with
author gish jen
yes i'm i'm thinking what you might
think of this using the same standards
and the feelings that you have toward
the authors and the books that you love
personally you know thinking of their
words and the flow of them that you
mentioned earlier in your in uh certain
authors which musicians singer
songwriters and certain albums do you
love
oh so which musicians do i love
oh wow that is a much harder question to
answer you know
i actually love
all kinds of music so i love jazz i love
classical i love pop but one thing
that's really kind of noticeable about
what i always love is that you know i
love vocal music
you know so you know if you you know any
good thing you know i will take choral
music over orchestral music any day um
and it is like i to me and i'm not sure
how this
i don't know how this relates to my
writing i don't know but
maybe because i'm interested in voice um
um but you know i love to hear the human
voice you know and um
like i say whatever the human race is
doing
i want to hear it
we didn't get to this yet and i want to
make sure that our viewers see this and
we get it on record some of your
favorite books
and what you're reading now king lear
jane austen's pride and prejudice leo
tolstoy's war and peace
and then we already talked about robert
fitzgerald's
translations of the iliad in the odyssey
currently reading though
elif
batuman uh-huh did i say that right i'm
not even sure i think it's i always say
batman but i actually don't know i've
never heard right
yeah
um
waiki wong waka oh i don't actually know
that's how she says it either let me
just say that in chinese it would be
wake up but i don't actually know how to
okay
wong the possessed chemistry by rachel
kushner uh
wicca wong world chemistry i apologize
and rachel kushner wrote the mars room
the mars room yeah as well as the
flamethrower is there is there a
connection between those books that
we're looking at right now on the screen
yes actually i would say that there is a
connection um yes you know they're all
books where there's
where they have a really clear
sensibility and i answered that word
early right all these books you know
it's like it's not just the material you
could sort of say yes there's a lot
because especially the mars room is um
is very concerned with you know with the
women in prison and you could say that's
very sociological but the sensibility
that she brings to the subject is really
quite extraordinary and it does take
something that might seem to have kind
of a predictable quality you know for
you know liberals or various stripes um
uh and it does and and kind of it really
uh it takes that material and just
really transcends the material and the
writing is just extraordinary um and i
would say that the same thing with with
the all the all of these books it's true
of all of them um
i think interestingly um all all three
of these authors have such strong voices
that you feel that you would follow them
everywhere and you don't really care
where they're going you know it's not
the stuff is not about plot it really
very much about
voice and sensibility and i will say in
originality because i think that in all
three cases you know you are reading a
voice
that is unlike anything you've ever read
before and that's even for those of us
who have read hundreds of thousands of
books
gisjen has been our guest for the past
three hours typical american was her
first book mona in the promised land
after that who's irish the love wife
world in town was her most recent novel
in her last two books both non-fiction
tiger writing and the girl at the
baggage claim gish jen thank you for
being
on in depth it's been such a pleasure
c-span where history unfolds daily
in 1979 c-span was created as a public
service by america's cable television
companies